Wenn ich hier eine Leitung kriege, zum Beispiel.
Na, geht gar nicht, wieso nicht?
Das ist immer, wenn wir da sind, dann klappt sowas überhaupt nie mehr. Ah egal, egal, also so in dem Fall, die Töne, die man eigentlich hört.
Ich wollte nur live wählen, aber es ist egal.
Machen wir nachher noch anders? Also es gibt ein Spielchen, Herr Frank, bitte.
Und wer dann halt die Töne zusammenreibt in der richtigen Reihenfolge, wenn sie natürlich nicht alle in der richtigen Reihenfolge sagen, und auch nicht alle nacheinander, der kann dann daraus eine Nummer rekonstruieren. Und wer diese Nummer dann anruft, wird dann irgendwo landen und hat dann einen Preis gewonnen.
Da gibt es zwei Schwierigkeitsstufen auch noch, ne?
Genau, ja.
Wir fangen auch jetzt noch nicht an, sondern es gibt eine für richtige Freaks mit pH. Da spielen wir die Nummer einmal schnell hintereinander vor, oder ein paar mal schnell. Das heißt, wer sie dann schon rauskriegt, der hat einen Sonderpreis gewonnen.
Vor allem spielen wir sie dann nicht mit in DTMF-Tönen, sondern in C5. Also das, was die internationalen Vermittlungsstellen untereinander benutzen, das ist dann noch ein bisschen schwieriger.
Wer soll das wissen?
Da gibt es genügend Leute.
Na gut, da sind wir dann überrascht. Ihr habt natürlich auch während dieser Sendung Zeit hier anzurufen, entweder Fragen zu stellen zum Thema Telefon, was man Witziges damit machen kann, oder von euren Telefon-Freaking-Aktionen berichten, falls ihr sowas macht. Wir behandeln eure Anrufe natürlich streng vertraulich. Ist der Recorder an, der zwischen der Leitung hängt hier?
Ja, ja, das ist alles.
Rückverfolgungsmechanismus, also ist kein Problem hier anzurufen. Ihr könnt uns E-Mail schicken, natürlich wie es sich für eine Computersendung gehört, chaos.orb.de, das landet dann hoffentlich auf dem Schreibtisch.
In dem Zusammenhang muss ich mich noch mal entschuldigen, wir haben eine Mail gekriegt, das letzte Mal, wo sich jemand beschwerte, dass wir Mails gar nicht vorlesen, weil er uns eine geschickt hatte und die kam nicht, das haben wir nicht getan, da haben wir einfach nicht rechtzeitig geguckt, die haben wir nach der Sendung. Ich glaube, Johnny hat sie bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Ich hab's aufgesehen, ich krieg's an.
Wir werden da jetzt ein bisschen besser verantworten.
Also haben wir hier einen Telefonspieler, das heißt wir spielen die Töne in lockerer Reihenfolge einzeln vor und sagen euch dann die wievielte Stelle in der Telefonnummer, die ihr wählen müsst, das ist und wenn die ganze Nummer nachher zusammen ist, sammelt euch auch Bescheid und wer es rausgefunden hat.
Kann dann diese, das ist ja noch nicht auf, pass mal nochmal.
Erstmal laufen. Technik, ja ja Technik. Also das alles heute rund ums Telefon im Chaos Blumen, unsere Telefonnummer, falls ihr euch einmischen wollt, ist 0331 zur Potsdam 74 81 110. Gleich legen wir los mit ein paar technischen Hinweisen, damit ihr überhaupt wisst, worum es geht.
Das ist hier den Klapperschrank. Da waren so Nummern obendran, die mit Magneten gehalten wurden. Wenn man jetzt also da angerufen hat, klappte die Nummer runter, die Dame vom Amt wusste also, um welchen Apparat es sich handelte. Das war so um 1877. Und konnte sich dann mit diesem Teilnehmer in Verbindung setzen, ihn fragen, wen er denn sprechen wollte, dann gucken, wer das wohl sein möge und da ein Kabel verbinden, gucken, ob der andere schon spricht. Wenn er nicht spricht, den anrufen, fragen, ob er dieses Gespräch entgegennehmen möchte, dann diese Verbindung herstellen und wenn die fertig gesprochen hatte, dann hat der Anrufende ein Schlusszeichen gegeben und die Dame vom Amt hat also dieses Gespräch wieder unterbrochen. Dame vom Amt deswegen, weil ziemlich schnell diese Domäne aus den Händen der Männer gerissen wurden. Das war denen, weiß ich nicht, zu anstrengend oder wie auch immer. Jedenfalls...
Es war denen zu anstrengend, war nicht schlecht. Halsvermittlung.
Ja nein, es gibt da hier, wir haben ja ein ganzes Buch, da geht es um die ganzen Telefonunfälle und Telefonistinnenkrankheiten. Also das war schon irgendwie nicht so ein ganzes Thema.
Was hat man da als Krankheiten bekommen?
Ich hab das nicht ganz durchgelesen, müssen wir mal gucken.
Da ging es teilweise darum, dass die irgendwelche Schläge gekriegt haben, ständig elektrisiert wurden und solche Sachen.
Aber dann hat die doch alles mitgehört, was man da kommt.
Die hat alles mitgehört, ja, ja. Das war auch die Ursache dafür, dass dann irgendwann, etwas später, der sogenannte Hebdrehwähler erfunden würde. Und zwar von dem Alman Beasts Trouger aus Kansas City. Das war ein Bestattungsunternehmer und er hat sich furchtbar darüber aufgeregt, dass die Dame vom Amt immer die Todesfälle einem Konkurrenten von ihm zugeschanzt hat, wenn sie das mitgehört hat. Dann hat er sich so aufgeregt, dass er eine Firma gegründet hat und diesen Hebdrehwähler zur automatischen Verbindungsvermittlungsaufbau erfunden hat. Das war irgendwie 1910, 1908 hat er das Patent angemeldet. In Deutschland wurde das 1910 in Betrieb genommen in Hildesheim. Und da ist das System sofort zusammengebrochen, weil nämlich alle Leute das erstmal ausprobieren mussten. Und zwar mit dem Nummer 2451, die ansässige Wurstfabrik, bezeichnenderweise, weil diese Nummer durch Zufall auf dem Werbeplakat für Hebdrehwähler abgedruckt gewesen ist. Dann sind da sämtliche Sicherungen rausgeknallt, es kam zu Muld an der Vermittlungsstelle und die haben erstmal das Dienstgebäude gestürmt. Das konnte dann später ein bisschen behoben worden.
Erste Fehler der Telekom.
Damals war das noch nicht Telekom. Also so funktionierte das. Bis 1945 gab das dann in Deutschland 1,657 Millionen Teilnehmer bundesweit. Die Fernverbindungen waren alle immer noch handvermittelt. 1957 gab das dann insgesamt 451 Vermittlungsstelle. Nur mal so ein paar Daten am Rande. Das Ganze wurde dann so 1966 behoben. Da waren sie dann alle automatisch vermittelt. Da wurde in Uezen die letzte Handvermittlungsstelle beendet, außer Betrieb genommen. Und seitdem ist es tatsächlich möglich, mit solchen Anlagen Unfug zu machen. Und da werden wir im Laufe der Sendung noch massiv darauf einlegen.
Ich hab irgendwo gelesen, da weiß ich nicht, ob jemand von euch was darüber weiß, dass die Engländer sich lange gegen Telefone gewehrt haben, dass sie das für totalen Humbug hielten, dass es dann irgendwann zwei Telefone gab im ganzen Land und die gesagt hätten, das brauchen wir nicht, wir haben ganz normal hier Briefdienst und so, wer will denn sowas?
Das erinnert mich irgendwie daran, neulich bin ich auf der Strecke nach Hannover an einem Bahnhofsgebäude vorbeigekommen, da stand eine Brieftaubensstelle, deutsche Bundesbahn, da dachte ich mir wahrscheinlich mal an die Baustellen.
Muss man da irgendwie, wie viel Vermittlung heute?
Alles digital?
Nein, noch nicht alles digital. Es gibt in Deutschland, ich glaube, ungefähr 8000 Vermittlungsstellen, davon sind 1000 digital. Es werden aber wesentlich, also wenn alles digital ist, wird es insgesamt irgendwie keine 8000 Vermittlungsstellen mehr geben, sondern nur noch 2000 oder 3000, falls sie natürlich eine wesentlich größere Kapazität haben als die alten Analogen. Naja, das soll also in Deutschland irgendwie bis, also laut Telekom Ende 97 alles digital sein, wird aber irgendwie nicht zu schaffen sein. Also inoffiziell wird bei der Telekom irgendwie gesagt, am 300. Dezember 97 ist dann alles digital.
Gibt es eigentlich, sinken die Möglichkeiten, um Ruck und Schabernack zu tragen eigentlich, wenn alles digital wird, oder steigen die?
Ja, das ist schwer zu sagen. Ich denke mal, komplexe Systeme machen komplexe Fehler. Je komplexer ein System wird, umso schwieriger ist es das, fehlerfrei zu halten. Umso schwieriger ist es dann aber auch, die Fehler zu finden letzten Endes. Also es hält sich so ein bisschen die Waage, würde ich fast sagen.
Also es wird eigentlich nicht wirklich weniger, es wird hauptsächlich anders.
Also grundsätzlich ist es ja so, dass diese Telekom-Vermittlungsstellen dann mit Software betrieben werden, mit allen Konsequenzen, die das so hat. Wenn man sich so die Qualität von Software heutzutage anguckt, man schaltet nur mal so einen PC ein.
Tja, ich lass das mal so stehen.
Jetzt hab ich hier auf einem wunderbaren Ablaufplan irgendwie so schöne Sachen wie, was tut eine Telefongesellschaft?
Stichpunkt Kohle kassieren.
Was mich schon immer mal interessiert hat und vielleicht auch einige unserer Hörer, diese komischen Nummern, wo andere Leute kassieren, wie funktioniert das? Also so Telefon-Stacks, der ganze Kram 0190 und so weiter, wäre Fernsehen zu zweit nicht viel schöner?
Naja, das funktioniert einfach folgendermaßen, da denkt sich jemand, schöne Ansage und so weiter. Also das sind ja meistens echt nur Ansagen, die dann da halt laufen und irgendwelche Tonbände. Und das wird dann eben auf eine Nummer geschaltet, also in Deutschland sind das 0190 Nummern. Also die fangen mit 0190 an. Und da ist es dann so, dass sich die Telekom und der Betreiber dieser Nummer die Einnahmen teilen. Und das wird dann halt ziemlich hoch tarifiert. Also das geht jetzt je nachdem, welche Ziffern nach der 0190 steht, sind das entweder von 80 Pfennig über 1, 20, 2, 40 bis hoch zu 3, 60 die Minute. Und der Betreiber, der Nummer, kriegt halt ungefähr die Hälfte, etwas weniger, wenn es im intelligenten Netz passiert, und die Telekom halt die andere Hälfte.
Also mit anderen Worten, ich könnte bei der Telekom anrufen und sagen, ich möchte gerne so eine 0190 Nummer haben, weiß nicht, vielleicht vorher irgendwie in einer Form da gründen. Und dann bespreche ich einen Anrufbeantworter, der auf diese Nummer geschaltet ist mit Hallo, schön, dass du anrufst, hier ist Johnny. Zur Zeit hebe ich gerade meinen Rock oder irgendwie sowas und dann verdiene ich ganz viel Geld, ohne dass ich was tun muss.
So ungefähr, also ganz so einfach läuft es nicht, aber im Prinzip ist das so, ja.
Hat das schon mal jemand gemacht von euch? Also ich meine nicht den Rock gehoben, sondern Was, war angerufen?
Nein, dass ihr nichts anders macht, wenn ihr hier seid, weiß ich ja.
Nein, ich meine, so eine 0190 hat man selber genutzt, versucht Geld zu verdienen damit.
Ja, also wir kennen diverse Leute, die sowas probieren, aber normalerweise kommen die, wenn die halt irgendwie richtig offene Systeme betreiben, nicht irgendwie auf ihre Marge.
Sag mal, das Rauschen hier so, hört das jemand? Ja, stimmt, wir haben eine Echo, schön, das Technik.
Wenn ich eure Mikros runterziehe, wird es besser, ihr piept.
Nee, gar nicht.
Nee, deine Kopfhörer sind undicht.
Nein, doch.
Wollen wir da jetzt drüber streiten oder wollen wir jetzt nicht?
Achso, du hast die Blöder. Du hast die Plattengeräusche von den Laptops.
Computer, okay, jetzt geht weiter.
Naja, wie viel Geld verdienen konnte man ja noch vor einiger Zeit mit diesen Doppel-Null-Sex-Nummern, die dann auch nicht den deutschen Reinhardsgeboten für Telefonangebote unterworfen waren. Ach, da gibt es Gesetze, ja? Ja, da gibt es so eine freiwillige Selbstkontrollgeschichte, wo man halt, wenn man 190er anbieten will, da muss man dann Mitglied werden und dann darf man halt keine unsichtlichen Angebote irgendwie unterbreiten. Also es muss dann alles irgendwie jugendfrei und so.
Moment mal, also ich ruf ein Sexnummer an und da passiert dann nichts?
Naja, du kannst es ja mal ausprobieren, diese ganzen Fernsehreklame, die sind immer deutlich vielversprechender als das, was dann da hinterher tatsächlich passiert.
Naja, aber ehrlich gesagt, die Fernsehreklame haben doch nicht so richtig viel.
Naja, die sind vielleicht nur die...
Also okay, jetzt sag ich jetzt Geschmackssache. Die sind halt ungefähr so erotisch wie die Bravo, aber naja. Also es gibt halt irgendwie von der Telekom halt die Aussage, dass bestimmte Inhalte halt nicht irgendwie verbreitet werden dürfen. Bis vor einiger Zeit war es so, dass überhaupt gar kein Sex für 190ern möglich war. Seit Anfang dieses Jahres ist es so, dass halt irgendwie animierende Angebote oder so sind wohl erlaubt, aber irgendwie richtig explizite Sachen wohl nicht. Bloß da hält sich halt kaum jemand dran, weil irgendwie müssen Leute ja auch hier Geld kaufen.
Gut, das werden wir nachher in der Sendung testen, so nach 12 Uhr, weil dann seid ihr alle im Bett. Dann nennen wir euch zum ersten Mal die gesamte Nummer, die ihr wählen müsst, um hier zu gewinnen, vorspielen. Ja, ist ganz klar. Ist ein Potsdamer gleich gehört?
Ich glaube, da war eine 4 drin.
Ich glaube auch.
Es ist jede Ziffer einmal drin. Minus so einmal.
Oh, wollen wir sie nochmal vorspielen? Ich hab reingeredet.
Gut, dann werden wir mal warten.
Jetzt ist ja klar.
Komisch.
Na ja, wir werden ja sehen, wenn es klingelt. Dann leuchtet nämlich ein rotes Lämpchen und dann werden wir sehen, ob das so schon jemand rausgefunden hat. Das würde einen Sonderpreis geben, und zwar eine Flugreise.
Ach nee, das hat nicht geklappt mit der Flugreise.
Mal denken, mal sehen, was das aus.
Auf jeden Fall was mit Computern zusammenhängt.
Ein Scherwer-Programm.
Und wir haben ein kleines Spiel für euch vorbereitet. Ich sag mal, wir. Ich hab damit ja nicht so richtig viel zu tun.
Die Chaos...
Die Chaoten.
Die Chaos Jungs haben für euch ein Spiel vorbereitet. Die fünfte Ziffer in einer Telefonnummer, die wir suchen, haben wir euch bereits vorgespielt. Es folgen jetzt die erste und dritte Stelle. Erstmal die erste vielleicht. Das ist die erste Stelle der Telefonnummer, die wir suchen. Wollen wir die nochmal spielen, die erste? Okay, und jetzt spielen wir euch gleichzeitig, damit es ein bisschen fixer geht, hier auch noch die dritte vor.
Die dritte nochmal vielleicht.
Erste und dritte Stelle von der Telefonnummer, die wir suchen, war das.
Ich muss das wieder abhacken, hier immer ein bisschen Buch.
Dann sollten wir vielleicht auch jetzt mal eine von den Nummern schon durchgeben, für die anderen. Also die erste Nummer, das hat keiner so schnell mitgekriegt. Aber ich mach mal einen Regler auf, soll ich?
Oder nicht?
Ihr sagt mir Bescheid. Ihr erklärt nochmal, worum es geht. Wir gehen jetzt DTMF-Töne durch, also die Pieps-Töne, die ihr am Telefon hört. Wir spielen so alle paar Minuten einen vor und sagen euch dann, die wievielte Stelle in der Telefonnummer, die wir suchen, das ist. Derjenige oder diejenige, die zuerst dann im Laufe dieser Sendung bei uns hier durchkommt, wir haben da ein paar Tricks eingebaut, aber das ist egal. Die Nummer, die ihr rausbekommt, müsst ihr anrufen. Und so viel kann ich sagen, das ist nicht die 0331 74 81 110. Der oder die hat was Schönes gewonnen, ein kleines Überraschungspaket. Das hat garantiert mit Computern zu tun. Mit anderen Worten, wir wissen nicht genau, was drin ist. Ja, soll ich?
So, das war die fünfte Ziffer aus der Telefonnummer.
Sollen wir nochmal oder?
Nochmal.
Okay, das war die fünfte Ziffer und zwar ziemlich lang. Warte mal, ich mach mal hier einen kleinen Haken hin, dass wir die fünfte schon gespielt haben. Insgesamt die fünfte.
Insgesamt die fünfte.
Also er weiß schon.
Die fünfte insgesamt, hat er gesagt.
Okay, also das ist die fünfte Nummer. Wenn ihr die schon mal rausfindet, jetzt in Ruhe, dann habt ihr schon mal die fünfte Nummer, eine Telefonnummer.
Bitte noch nicht anrufen, beziehungsweise... Da gibt es ja nur noch drei Millionen Möglichkeiten.
Und ruft bitte erst an, wenn ihr euch wirklich sicher seid, nicht, dass ihr irgendwie auf einzelne Leute aus dem Bett klingelt, die davon belästigt.
Bitte nicht den Radiomotor wandern.
Ach, macht er was, was er wollt.
Hallo?
Komm, wir machen jetzt noch mal zwei Nummern. Noch mal drei Nummern?
Wir machen zwei Nummern.
Ihr hört Chaosradio, ihr könnt uns erreichen unter chaos.op.de oder unter 0331 für POP STUMP, 74 181 110. Lasst uns zwei Nummern machen und dann ein bisschen telefonieren, weil es rufen viele Leute an.
Gut, dann kommt jetzt die sechste Nummer.
Ah, Moment, ich muss erst aufmachen. Warte, jetzt. Ich komme mir ein bisschen vor wie Hans Rosenthal. Das gehörte Signal ist die sechste Ziffer unserer gesuchten Telefonnummer.
Und die zweite, denke ich jetzt.
Sie sind der Meinung, das war......spitze!
Das war jetzt die sechste.
Und jetzt kommt die zweite.
Nummer.
Ach sag mal, gibt es da nicht so einen Songbook, was man auf dem Telefon spielen kann für Melodien? Hat das jemand mit? Nö, ist klar, wenn wir eine Sendung über witzige Sachen mit dem Telefon machen. Zwei, drei, vier fehlen noch. Jetzt kommen die Zehnte.
Nummer war das, meine Damen und Herren.
Die 10.
Nummer in der gesuchten Lösungsnummer.
Noch eine mehr oder? Das war die siebte Nummer in unserer gesuchten Lösungsnummer. Momentan es nähert sich dem Ende, es fehlen nur noch zwei Nummern. Probiert nicht zu viel rum. Wir geben die letzten beiden Töne jetzt durch und wer dann anruft, der oder die hat nochmal gewonnen.
Also, als erstes mal die achte Ziffer.
Moment, ja, ist offen.
Das war die achte Ziffer, okay.
Noch einmal. Gut, jetzt haben wir sie alle.
Klingelt.
Wir müssen jetzt das Gewinnspiel mal wieder ein bisschen in Gang bringen.
Ja, ich danke dir erstmal.
Bis dann.
Oliwans Klingeln jetzt hier die Leitungen heißt. Deswegen mal kurz gucken, was passiert. Wir machen aber erst mal noch das Gewinnspiel. Wir haben zwei weitere Nummern für euch, die erste, dritte und fünfte der Telefonnummer, die ihr nachher möglichst schnell wählen sollt, um hier zu gewinnen. Haben wir bereits.
Ja, jetzt kommt irgendwie die elfte.
Die elfte?
Wie viele sind das denn nochmal?
Ja logisch.
Das war die 11.
Nummer und was ist dann noch eine dritte Nummer?
Okay, dann machen wir noch die 9.
Ah, das klang mir aber verdächtig nach einer einstelligen Zahl. Das war die neunte und davor haben wir die elfte Nummer gehört. Also es fehlen euch nur noch wenige, damit ihr die Nummer rauskriegt. Ich bin mal gespannt, wer hier als erster nachher anruft.
Soll ich mal die siebte vorspielen?
Nee, das ist die neunte.
Das war die nahe.
Das war die unvollendete von Tim. Kannst du nachher dann den ganzen Satz bringen. Aber erst nach 1 Uhr bitte. Oh, hier klingelt eine Nummer, das kann nicht sein.
Warte mal, redet mal weiter.
Zu diesem unzugelassenen Telefon, da gibt es ein lustiges Dolmets.
Das kann nicht sein, da hat jemand angerufen und aufgelegt.
Der wusste es.
Das rote Telefon hat geklingelt.
Die hat mir jemand erzählt.
Wir wollen ja kurz ein technisches Problem lösen, denn wir haben einen Gewinner. Zehn, ist der jetzt automatisch drauf?
Nee, noch nicht.
Felix ist drauf, wunderbar.
Ich glaube, dann können wir da auflegen, oder?
Wunderbar funktioniert. So, immer alle Mikros auf. Das ging jetzt ein bisschen hektisch. Ja, Felix ist nicht doof und Felix hat gewonnen. Und zwar hat er deswegen gewonnen, weil ihr am Anfang gesagt habt, es kommt jede Nummer einmal vor.
Scheiße.
Okay, Felix, Felix, sag uns nicht die Nummer, die du angerufen hast. Ich würde sagen, wir vergeben noch einen zweiten Preis, wenn wir die anderen beiden Ziffern auch noch durchgegeben haben. Für diejenigen, die es dann vielleicht mit allen Zahlen rausgefunden haben wirklich.
Aber für Cleverness gibt es auf jeden Fall einen extra Preis.
Wollen wir uns die Methode lösen, mit der ich es rausgefunden habe?
Die Methode sollst du sagen?
Ja, erzähl mal.
Und zwar, ich habe ja bei mir privat eine Telefonanlage. Und an einem Anschluss hängt ein Zeichelmodem dran mit Spracherkennung.
So hatten wir uns das ja auch vorgestellt.
Kann man das jetzt für die anderen Hörer nochmal erklären?
Ja, und zwar habe ich dann mit einem Telefon das Modem angerufen. Das Modem habe ich so initialisiert, dass es MSV-Töne erkennt und mir auf dem Bildschirm schreibt. Und du liest den Rechner schon die ganze Zeit her. Und das Telefon hatte fleißig aufs Radio mitgehört und malte mir wunderschöne Titeln auf dem Bildschirm.
Felix, du darfst dich ab heute mit pH vorne schreiben.
Als echter Telefonfreak.
Bleib kurz am Apparat, ich muss deine Adresse aufschreiben, dann kriegst du von uns ein Paket zugeschickt. Und wir machen das Spiel aber noch weiter. Also Felix ist jetzt erster Gewinner mit einem Sonderpreis, nicht klein, mit einem Sonderpreis, weil er die letzten zwei Nummern einfach so rausgefunden hat. Wir machen aber noch weiter, wir geben euch die auf jeden Fall durch, denn so einfach ist das ja alles nicht. Allerdings, muss ich sagen, hätte man vorher vielleicht nichts sagen sollen, dass jede Nummer einmal voll ist.
Voll okay finde ich voll okay.
Voll okay. Ja, jetzt klingelt das Telefon natürlich hier heiß. Jetzt haben es mehrere rausgefunden, obwohl wir die letzten beiden Nummern noch nicht durchgegeben haben. Wer immer jetzt gerade am Telefon ist, wenn du uns hörst, bleib mal kurz dran noch, weil wir haben noch zwei andere Hörer, mit denen wir telefonieren und dann nehmen wir dich ran. Die Leitung von der Nummer, die ihr erraten soll, ist also jetzt im Moment wahrscheinlich besetzt. Oder es geht keiner ran, je nachdem. Es ist übrigens keine Fritz-Nummer.
Fritz klingen alle möglichen Telefone.
Es ist keine Fritz-Nummer. Also so klarer sind wir natürlich auch. Wir haben jetzt nicht irgendeine Nummer genommen und dann einfach andere Durchwahl hinten. Das ist eine völlig andere Nummer. Aber jetzt scheint es nicht mehr ganz so schwer zu sein. Seid ihr jetzt so ein bisschen, seid ihr jetzt enttäuscht oder bestätigt?
Zumindest scheint er uns irgendwelche Leute zuzuhören.
Ich bin eigentlich eher erfreut, weil wäre es nicht so gewesen, dann hätten wir überhaupt nicht über Technik reden können.
Ich hatte eher das eventuell gar keiner anruft oder so, aber das zeigt doch, dass da draußen doch eine ganze Menge Leute gibt, die sich damit halt so richtig beschäftigen.
Tobias wieder in wahnwitziger Selbstüberschätzung als er ja der Einzige, der da so in der Lage wäre.
Wo sind die CCCITT 5 Leute?
Die hat man nicht, vor allen Dingen, weil wie schreibt man das? Ähm, wir machen kurz noch zwei Tiefenleute, die ich jetzt hier auf die Leitung gestellt hab. Und dann gucken wir, wer jetzt am Telefon hängt.
Warte mal, bleibst du noch kurz dran? Okay.
Ich hoffe, er hat ja gesagt, habe ich gehört.
Weil das ist ein richtiges Telefon, was hier steht. Und das andere läuft über die Telefonanlage.
Hallo. Das ist Hallo Joachim.
Auch du hast die Nummer rausgefunden.
Ja, ganz einfach.
Ganz einfach, okay.
Ganz einfach.
Sag's dir nicht an, aber erzähl wie.
Ich hab einfach den Piepster genommen, das Fernabfragegerät vom Anrufbeantworter und hab das so ans andere Ohr gehalten, ein Ohr ans Radio, das Gerät, und hab einfach die Töne verglichen.
Das ist oldschool.
Ist das vorher aufgezeichnet oder erst nur in dem Moment?
Nur in dem Moment.
Das ist aber nicht schlecht.
Das ist okay. Das ist gutes Gehirn.
Und die letzten zwei Nummern dann geraten?
Ja, der erste Anruf sagt ja schon, jede Nummer kommt nur einmal vor. Die andere Nummer war dann kein Anschluss unter dieser Nummer, also wurde nur noch eine Möglichkeit übrig.
Das ist wohl wahr, ja. Aber es kann ja sein, dass jemand eine von den schon angegebenen Nummern falsch hat. Wir geben also auf jeden Fall auch noch die anderen beiden durch. Und einer wird dann auch noch gewinnen, außer dir und außer Felix.
Was hat denn bei der Sportliche unter den beiden?
Ich finde auch, das gibt einen Sportler-Extrapreis. Kriegst du einen Packung Isostar? Nee, da werden wir uns auch für dich noch was einfallen lassen. Ich habe eine Frage noch. Kommst du auch aus Dresden?
Ich komme aus Thüringen, wohne aber in Berlin.
War nur eine Frage, weil ich habe so den Eindruck, dass unheimlich viele Telefone für dich in Dresden wohnen. Ich weiß nicht genau warum. Kann diese Vermutung jemand bestätigen?
Weil es da kein Westfernsehen gab.
Ja, dann bleib noch kurz dran.
Ich schreibe auch gleich deine Adresse auf.
Gut, jetzt haben wir sie alle.
Klingelt schon.
Jetzt klingelt es gerade.
Hallo, ich kann dich nicht hören.
Ich bin ein Hörer.
Falls du mich hörst, bleib kurz dran. Moment. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Wer ist da? Matthias, hallo.
Wie hast du es rausgefunden?
Ja, bisschen technischer Art und Weise.
Ach so.
Du klingst doch auch sechselnd. Du klingst auch ein bisschen sechselnd.
Ja, richtig.
Heuer ist es bei dir.
Ich bin in Sachsen.
Siehst du, die ganzen Telefonfreaks sitzen in Sachsen.
Ja, scheint so.
Komisch. Ihr seid die Letzten, die Telefon gekriegt haben. Musstest du euch was einfallen lassen oder wie?
Ja, möglich, aber wir hatten es schon eine Weile.
Nächstes Mal geh ich auf die Sechsel-Sparlisse.
Das ist unser Vorsprung.
Gut, erzähl mal, wie du es geschafft hast.
Ja, ich hab mal nachgedacht.
Die erste Ziffer hab ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Die hab ich nur durch probieren. Nee, durch die letzte fehlende Zahl so bemerkt.
Dann hab ich mir überlegt.
Ich hab irgendwie ein Funkgerät.
Das funktioniert ja auch mit DTMF Tönen.
Und das hab ich als Decoder benutzt.
Kleinen extra Applaus für dich.
An dich geht Milka Sport.
Wir sollten zunächst die Olympiade Elektro Sport als eigene.
Diese Nummer ist jetzt damit nicht mehr anzurufen. Die ist jetzt gestorben. Jetzt ist Feierabend mit dieser Nummer.
Es ist eine Nummer, die wir angegeben haben, unter einer Rufumleitung nach hier gemacht. Also tut uns einen Gefallen. Seid sportlich, seid fair und ruft diese Nummer, wenn ihr sie jetzt auch raus habt. Es gibt keine Gewinne mehr. Wir haben drei Gewinner, die sich alle sehr sportlich verhalten haben und sehr schnell waren, wie ich finde. Aber ruft uns bitte diese Nummer nicht mehr an. Die wird mich von anderen Leuten dann teilweise doch noch gebraucht. Also ich hoffe, dass wir da jetzt ein bisschen an euch appellieren können in eurer Telefon-Freak-Ethik. Ja, dann musst auch du kurz am Telefon bleiben. Wir schreiben auch deine Adresse auf. Und auch du bekommst ein kleines Chaosradio-Überraschungspaket.
Okay, wunderbar.
Ein riesiges.
Ja, na siehst du, da hatte irgendjemand Angst, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Was denn?
Ich hab hier noch die Ukraine.
Oh, die Ukraine, erzähl.
Können wir nochmal testen?
Den Computer?
Ich versteh das nicht.
Das ist kein Anschluss hinter dieser Nummeransage von einer japanischen Telefongesellschaft.
Mach den nochmal bitte.
Ne, wir haben noch ein paar andere Schichten.
Es gibt noch sehr viel mehr schöne Sachen.
Wir können auch Myanmar machen.
This is International Gateway Exchange Myanmar. You dialed the wrong number. Please contact your home gateway exchange for further information.
Myanmar. Jemals Boma glaub ich, ne?
Die von Ihnen gewählte Code Nummer für den gewünschten südafrikanischen Bereich ist ungültig. Bitte stimmen Sie sie mit Ihrem internationalen Schaltamt ab.
Dann hätte ich auch gar nochmal.
Äh, wie macht man sowas?
Mit dem internationalen Schaltamt?
Das ist doch doch auch nicht. Wer ist dafür?
Sie ist ja nett.
Glaube, du sagst, dass es ähnlich ist wie, das läuft hier überhaupt nicht, Jungs. Ich würde gerne nach hier nochmal den japanischen hören.
Den japanischen? Wir haben noch einen zweiten japanischen. Das ist der Klassiker.
Das habe ich ziemlich genau verstanden.
Das heißt, wenn Sie sich jetzt tierisch aufregen, wenn Sie nicht durchkommen, bleiben Sie einfach ruhig.
Da ist ein Problem, die Faxkannung ändern. Zwei Nummern. Probier nicht zu viel rum.
Telecom in New Zealand schreibt, dass das Nummer, das Sie gebeten haben, entweder verändert oder nicht mehr erzielt werden kann.
Bitte an Ihren internationalen Direktoren-Service.
Was denn? Ich habe hier noch die Ukraine. Oh, die Ukraine, AC.
Ne vierno nabra mi nummer. The number was dialed incorrectly.
Ja, Ukraine schau ich schon.
Machen wir noch einen?
Machen wir noch einen.
Gute Mala können wir uns noch mal kennen.
Ja, mach mal Gute Mala.
El numero que usted marcó no existe en la red telefónica. El numero que usted marcó no existe en la red telefónica.
Kann ich bitte noch mal den allerersten hören? Na, erst japanisch und dann englisch weiter.
Den japanisch-englischen? Den mit der Melodie oder ohne Melodie?
Den ohne, den 81er.
Ja.
Die dialerierte Nummer kann nicht als Ersatz verwend werden.
Das ist ITJ.
Ah, der ist unwichtig, aber der erste ist doch schön, oder?
Der gehört dazu, das ist der zweite Teil.
Du darfst dich einfach mittendrin unterbrechen.
Nee, ach das Englische war schon machbar.
Du bleibst in deiner Moderatorenethik.
Nee, da spreche ich dann über das Ende rüber. Das macht mir gar nichts.
Nee, aber der Anfang ist doch schön mit diesem Avongong.
Und wie Ping-Pong.
Es ist Brunei Telekom. Der Nummer, den du gedauert hast, ist in Korea.
Your call could not be connected. Please check the number and try again. G-U-L-E-C-O-B-C-G-O-N-B.
Wer macht sowas bitte?
Von euch?
Du setzt dich hin und rufst diese ganzen Nummern an.
Na das war doch schon ganz schön viel Arbeit.
Das war nicht viel Arbeit, ich hab's nicht gemacht.
Aber macht Spaß, lustig.
Also man kann sich da irgendwie das Vorwahlverzeichnis nehmen von der Telekom und kann einfach mal irgendwelche Auslandsvorwahlen anrufen und dann dahinter viele Neuen oder viele Neuen wählen und dann einfach mal gucken, was passiert. Da muss man natürlich aufpassen, dass es nicht irgendwie plötzlich viel Geld kostet, aber ansonsten kann man damit viel Spaß haben.
Ja, woher weiß ich dann das? Also wenn ich jetzt gut Vorwahlverzeichnis nehme ich mir von Hürsel Mürselland und dann ruf ich da an.
Du nimmst einfach das, was du von der Telekom kriegst. Da stehen ja sämtliche Auslandsvorwahlen drin.
Gut und dann irgendeine fiktive Nummer, die hoffentlich nicht existiert.
Genau.
Und woher weiß ich, dass mich diese Nummer kann nicht gewählt werden, nichts kostet?
Ja, du solltest entweder bei einer Analogenleitung einen Gebührenimpuls haben oder eine ESDN-Leitung, wo dir die Gebühren angezeigt werden, ansonsten ist das etwas riskant.
Und sobald die in schneller Reihenfolge, die Ziffern 12, 24, 36 und so weiter auftauchen, sollte man wirklich schnell auflegen. Okay, also was ist denn nun, was ist aus eurer persönlichen Erfahrung das Abgefahrenste, was ihr jemals erlebt habt mit Telefon? Also ich kann ja mal zum Beispiel die erste Geschichte, die mich sehr beeindruckt hat, da werdet ihr sagen, hö alter Hut war, als ich mal in Amerika war, nachts in der Kneipe einen Typ kennengelernt und erzählt, ich bin aus Deutschland und er so, na da ist ja jetzt so und so viel Uhr, dann willst du ja sicher da mal anrufen. Ich so klar, er komme mit und dann mit dem aufs Klo gegangen, da dachte ich, na hallo, was will der von mir? Aber das war nur, weil die öffentlichen Telefonzellen da auf dem Männerklo waren und dann sagt er, ja wenn du jetzt anrufen willst, hier. Und drückte mir so ein kleines Kästchen in die Hand, sah aus wie so eine fernanrufbeantwortete Fernabfrage und sagte, hier drückst du immer rauf und es simuliert dann den Einwurf eines 25 Cent Stückes und dann kannst du so lange telefonieren, wie du willst. Und das hat funktioniert, ich hab da gestanden, musste zwar alle anderen 30 Sekunden auf diesen Knopf drücken, weil es so ein bisschen nervig war, aber ich hab umsonst hat Deutschland telefoniert. So, das geht nur in Staaten, stimmt's?
Das geht nur in Staaten, das nennt sich Redbox, das Verfahren. Das ist halt wirklich so, da wird die Telefonzellen über Mittel in der Vermittlungsstelle durch Töne, was für Geldstücke eingeworfen werden. Also es gibt für 25, also für Quarter 25 Cent Stücke, gibt es einen Ton für 10 Cent und für 5 Cent Stücke. Und wenn man diese Töne eben selber einspielt, dann kann es unter Umständen sein, dass sie das akzeptieren. Also natürlich sind sie darauf aufmerksam geworden und sind etwas intelligenter geworden. Die Telefongesellschaften, das funktioniert längst nicht mehr überall und für Übersegespräche schon gar nicht. Da benutzt man dann halt eher Corlink Cards.
Ist auch schon ein bisschen her. Mit diesen Corlink Cards ist es dann ja im Endeffekt doch leichter. Man braucht ja noch jemanden über die Schulter gucken und seine Nummer aus schreiben.
Ja, aber das ist, da betrügt man sozusagen denjenigen dann ja, in dem man ihm eine hohe Rechnung gehört und viel Ärger und so weiter.
Die Kollegen, die hier vorher den Blackboard Jungle moderiert haben, haben übrigens die witzige Geschichte erzählt, dass jemand, den sie kennen, mal beim Abhören einer Telefonsext-Ansage eingeschlafen ist. Kommt vor, das ist jetzt eine völlig andere Geschichte, aber was passiert denn dann? Du schlägst ein, das Band läuft und läuft und läuft und im nächsten Mal hast du 1000 Mark Telefonrechnung.
In Deutschland gibt es eine Zeitbegrenzung. Das wird dann irgendwann abgeschaltet.
Aber noch nicht so lange.
Nee, noch nicht so lange und funktioniert auch nicht immer wegen technischer Probleme.
Sind doch 60 Minuten oder so, ne?
Irgendwie sowas.
Das reicht ja dann.
Das ist aber auch erst nach einiger Zeit eingeführt worden.
Kommt ja auch ein bisschen was zusammen. Was kann man denn überhaupt, was, was, ja gut jetzt vielleicht Anekdoten von euch.
Ja, als ich vor zwei Jahren irgendwie in Ameland war, da wusste ich diese Geschichte nicht, dass die das Problem mit den Redboxes hatten. Und hab halt probiert irgendwie mit Münzen halt in Deutschland anzurufen vom öffentlichen Telefon aus. Und hab überhaupt nicht realisiert, wieso der Operator da irgendwie ständig von mir erklären wollte. Also ich hätte jetzt ja prima irgendwie da 20 Quarters eingeschmissen, aber irgendwie wollte er mich immer noch nicht nach Deutschland Telefonieren machen. Und dann ständig von mir irgendwie den Sound hören wollte, wie die Münzen klappern, bis mir dann einfühlt, dass er wahrscheinlich dachte, dass ich da mit einer Redbox stehe. Wie hast du das dann gelöst?
Einer der Sender hat erzählt, wie blöde die Karten sind. Das war ja nicht meine.
Ich hatte neulich das, was heißt neulich vor einiger Zeit, ungefähr ein Jahr, hatte ich das mit Abstand teuerste Telefongespräch meines Lebens. Das Ganze fand in Malawi statt. Dazu muss man sagen, das handelt sich dabei um einen Staat, das wissen wahrscheinlich die meisten nicht. Und zwar um einen der unterentwickelsten dieser Erde, liegt südöstlich in Afrika, ganz tief drin. Dort gibt es 6-städtige Telefonnummern für das gesamte Land. Manche Städte haben halt gar keine. Oder auch nur eine einzige Nummer. Da sitzt ein Operator und kann auf bis zu weitere 10 Stellen weitervermitteln. Ich hatte nun das Problem, dass mir in diesem Land ein Rucksack entwendet wurde, so mit Pass und mit all diesen wichtigen Sachen.
Macht man ja gerne im Ausland.
Und es war einfach nur nötig, mit der Außenwelt Kontakt aufzunehmen. Das ist gar nicht so einfach, weil ein International Call ist erstmal so ein Wagnis. Einige Zeit später habe ich es nochmal probiert. Da war also noch nicht mal die Leitung bis zu dem International Operator zu holen. Geschweige denn irgendwie die Leitung nach draußen. Also ging ich in ein Hotel und führte dort mein Telefongespräch. Dieses Telefongespräch dauerte 30 Sekunden. Erst am nächsten Tag erfuhr ich, dass für diese 30 Sekunden mir zunächst einmal satte drei Minuten in Rechnung gestellt wurden. Das wäre also das Minimum für einen internationalen Anruf.
Alles klar.
Und das kostete mich dann schlappe 20 US-Dollar. 10 für die Telefongesellschaft und 10 für das Hotel.
Ne, das ist 20.
Achso, stimmt, hast du 20 gesagt. Hast du deinen Rucksack wiederbekommen?
Nein.
Wir haben eine E-Mail gekriegt, soll ich die vorlesen? Die dreht sich um... Kommt von Moment Müllers?
Nein, wie heißt der?
Steve, kommt von Steve, GTB wird noch von mir hören. Ich hab heute gerade mein erstes ISDN Kapitel abgeschlossen. Soll ich die Story vorlesen oder später? Warum nicht? Gut, dann les mal vor, ich leg mal ein bisschen Musik drunter, damit das ein bisschen schöner wird hier. Also E-Mail an ChaosOptiBear. Ich hab heute gerade mein erstes ISDN Kapitel abgeschlossen. Die Story. Vor drei Wochen habe ich eine Übernahme, in Klammern alter analoge Anschluss, um Schalten auf ISDN beantragt. Die NTBA habe ich gleich bei der Anmeldung mitgenommen, um mir die Technikergebühren zu sparen. Erfreulicherweise bekam ich zehn Tage später die Nachricht, dass der analoge Anschluss am 16.05. abgeschaltet und der ISDN Anschluss am Tag darauf geschaltet werden sollte. Erster Riss funktionierte wie angekündigt. Leider blieb die ISDN Schaltung aus. Seit Samstag, dem 18.05. habe ich dann täglich eine Woche lang bei der Telekom verschiedene Stellen, wie Störungsannahme, Telekom Service etc. angerufen und mich beschwert. Wie sind wir da durchgekommen?
Naja, kann ja nicht sein, dass der durchgekommen ist.
Am Donnerstag, dem 24.05. bequemte man sich endlich, mir einen Technikertermin zu geben. Ich war persönlich beim Service der Telekom erschienen. Dieser war heute da und überprüfte den Anschluss. Wie sich herausstellte, war der Anschluss am Montag, dem 20.05. ordnungsgemäß geschaltet worden, aber das Kabel von NTBA zur Telefonanlage von Telekom-Förderung überbezahlt. Defekt, das lag der Telefonanlage der Firma GTB bei. Das hat mich dann nochmal die Servicepauschale der Telekom von 65 Mark gekostet.
Ah ja, schon Witzige Geschichten.
Kann man sich anhören, wie die beiden Auskunftsoperator dann gegenseitig versuchen rauszufinden, was derjenige denn jetzt für eine Telefonnummer haben will und so weiter?
Bei den derzeitigen Auskunftskosten, das darf man dann nur bei Bekannten machen, oder?
Naja, oder man macht beim Pizzaservice.
Ah, Pizzaservice gegenseitig? Liefern die?
Du musst dir einfach mal die Situation vorstellen. Stell dir mal vor, hier würde ein Radiomoderator anrufen, der jetzt gerade erwartet, dass ihn da anruft.
Der live auf Sendung ist und ich sage, hey, du bist live auf Sendung und er sagt, hey, du auch.
Du willst mich verarschen, du auch.
Das wär natürlich nicht schlecht. Gibt es da irgendeine Sendung, bei der man jetzt live anrufen kann? Das könnten wir ja mal machen.
Spriradio.
Keine Ahnung, was das für eine Frequenz ist. Ich weiß es nicht. 03314 Potsdam 7418110 ist übrigens unsere Nummer, falls ihr was Lustiges erlebt habt.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Wer ist da? Hey, danke.
Schön, bei welchem Sender sind wir denn?
Wir haben bestimmt gleich eine Rückkopplung.
Waren wir eine Bäume zu gewonnen?
Wäre schön wenn, Ene.
So, das ist jetzt gar nicht egal, das mach ich nicht.
Ja, danke. Guck mal, ob jemand anderes noch witzige Schatze hat.
Hallo.
Hallo, ja hier ist der Marc.
Marc, hallo.
Ja, also ich wollte nur noch ein schönes Story erzählen zu ESDN, weil wir schon gerade dabei waren. Man kann ja auch vorraten. Vielleicht habt ihr das schon mal ausprobiert da drüben.
Rufanleitung?
Ja, genau, Rufanleitung. Also wenn man nicht da ist, kann man das Telefon ja umlegen sonstwo. Ihr habt da gerade ein nettes Mädel, das für einen Monat nach Hongkong ist. Weil auf Arbeit, deshalb, unser ESDN-Telefon einfach mal zu der Nummer da vorratet. Und dann kann ich abends da anrufen oder morgens, weil es da ein bisschen Zeitverschmutzung gibt.
Das Ganze ist ein Auslandsgespräch.
Bei welcher Firma arbeitest du? Und wie lange noch vor allen Dingen?
Das ist aber gängige Frage.
Aber ich würde sagen, wegen der technischen Möglichkeiten und der netten Sache, ist es eigentlich gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ich fasse da nochmal kurz zusammen für alle, die es jetzt nicht mitbekommen haben. Natürlich nur, um davor zu warnen. Bitte nutzen Sie diese Möglichkeit nicht. Und zwar funktioniert das so. Die meisten Arbeitgeber haben ja doch ISDN-Telefone. Und da kann man eine Rufumleitung einschalten. Und wenn deine Freundin gerade nach Tokio verreist ist, dann kannst du das Telefon deines Arbeitgebers, ein bestimmtes, was vielleicht nicht so oft benutzt wird, am besten. Tipps, toll. Mit einer Rufumleitung nach Tokio umschalten, einstellen und das möglichst wenig Leuten sagen. Und dann kann man selber da anrufen, hat nur, trägt nur die Ortsgebühren und der Rest trägt der Arbeitgeber.
Das Problem ist jetzt bei mir, dass das also ein 1-TL-6-Anschluss ist. Also da finden die Chaos Computer Leute ja gleich was zu sagen. Und das ganze Telefon schaltet auch, die also reagiert leider auch auf GlobaleCard und schaltet deshalb auch das Fax mit nach Hongkong. Und das ist jetzt mein Problem. Wie empfangen wir in der Nacht noch Faxe, wenn ich das da einprogrammiert habe? Da will ich jetzt ein eigenes Programm zu schreiben, weil ich ein bisschen Kapi programmieren kann. Und ihr solltet mir mal jetzt erzählen, das krieg ich nicht hin, dass ich da irgendwie mit Telefon die Kapi anrufe und dann irgendeinen Request und so machen muss.
Warte mal, du hast einen 1TR6 und der ist rufweitergeleitet?
Ja genau. Und ich will das selbst programmieren, damit ich genau auf eine Entausschreibung zu verwenden gehen kann.
Das Problem ist, dass 1TR6-Anschlüsse sich im Allgemeinen nur komplett umleiten lassen.
Ja, nicht die 1TR6.
Bei Euro ist es per Nummer. Du hast aber noch die Möglichkeit, das per Service zu machen bei 1TR6. Das heißt, entweder du schaltest Telefonie weiter oder Datendienste. Das Problem bei Fax ist, dass die meistens auch als normale Telefonie-Calls reinkommen.
Ja genau, ich schalte eine Logo rein und damit kann das nicht unterscheiden.
Die Lösung ist, sagt deinem Arbeitgeber, 1TR6 ist total veraltet und braucht unbedingt EDSS1.
Sag den Leuten, die anrufen, sollen andere Faxnummer benutzen.
Das blöde ist nur, bis die Telekom den Anschluss umgestellt hat, ist deine Freundin wahrscheinlich wieder da.
Oh ja, das stimmt, scheinbar.
Bei dir ist nur drei Jahre weg.
Oder sie fängt die Dinger einfach wieder zurück.
Hallo, Chaosradio hier. Hallo.
Dann du nichts sprechen hier.
Hallo, Chaosradio.
Hi, wer bist du denn? Ein Hai.
Also ich hab eine nette Sache am Laufen. Ich schalt mich bei der Deutschen Telekom ein über ein Relais und telefoniere gerade auf eure Kosten.
Ach.
Okay, sag mal, warte mal, wir nehmen dich mal hier so privat für uns, wir spielen ein bisschen Musik und du erklärst uns dann mal, wie das geht. Nee, erzähl noch mal.
Also ich hab ein Modem, geh über die Daten Autobahn zur Telekom rein, knack den Code, häng mich an das R-Gespräch Relais dran und telefoniere alle Telefonate auf R-Gespräch.
Glauben wir hier nicht.
Das kann man auch über Amerika machen, indem man sich ins amerikanische Telefonnetz einwählt.
Ich lasse jetzt hier noch Experten gegeneinander antreten. Kannst du ein paar, du musst ja nicht verraten, wie es geht, aber du könntest ja irgendwie, wie willst du beweisen, dass das stimmt?
Ja, ich denke das Beste ist, man probiert selber aus, man sucht sich die Telefonnummer vom amerikanischen Telefonnetz, von der amerikanischen Telekommunikation raus und geht in den Computer rein und dann lässt man sich über zwei gezeigen, wo man hin muss.
Ist klar.
Also ich suche jetzt mal...
Einmal Text sozusagen.
Am besten noch mit klicken. Also es ist wichtig, dass man...
Man braucht natürlich eine Soundkarte.
Läuft das auch schon auf CD-ROM?
Ich weiß im Moment nicht, wovon ihr redet.
Wir glauben dir nicht, das ist der Punkt. Also die amerikanische Telekommunikation hat auf gar keinen Fall eine Sammelnummer.
Dafür gibt es einfach viel zu viel...
Die amerikanische, da gehören auch noch ein paar komische Intensivitäten.
Du kannst uns ja einen kleinen Tipp... Du bist mit Modem unterwegs? Schick uns eine kurze E-Mail und so eine Andeutung. Chaos, also C-H-A-U-S-Ed-O-R-B-Punkt-D-E.
Also.
Das ist ja nicht so schwer. Chaos-Ed-O-R-B-Punkt-D-E kann man ja auch merken. Schick uns eine kurze E-Mail mit so ein paar Andeutungen und dann, wir überprüfen das mal, wir glauben das nicht.
Ja, in 15 Sekunden.
Ja, das ist die Zeit, also keine Hektik.
Ah, okay, doch Hektik, alles klar.
Chaos Radio, hallo.
Ich bin Yvonne.
Jens? Yvonne, hast du was Lustiges mit dem Telefon erlebt?
Ja, ich hab oft mit meiner Freundin Telefonstreiche gemacht. Also einmal, also die wurde, als man sie vorgesehen hat, die wurde von ihrer Familie ausgestoßen. Da hat man Telefonstreiche bei ihrer Oma gemacht.
Sag mal, Yvonne, warte mal kurz, du redest ein bisschen schnell.
Also, meine Freundin, wurde von ihrer Familie ausgestoßen. Und da haben wir einen Telefonstreich bei ihrer Oma gemacht. Also ich hab da angerufen und ihr Onkel wohnt noch bei ihrer Oma. Und dann hat der Paul, die wohnen in Bayern, und ich so, hallo, hier ist die Susi, ist der Paul da? Dann hat sie ihn rangeholt, dann hab ich aufgelegt. Dann hab ich nochmal angerufen und gesagt, hallo, hier ist die Susi, die Telefonleitung wurde unterbrochen, kann ich bitte nochmal den Paul haben? Und das ging dann fünfmal so weiter, bis sie dann irgendwann das Telefon gebrüllt hatten. Dann hab ich ihn aufgelegt. Dann kommen wir irgendwo durch und erzählen uns ein Schwachsinn.
Das ist aber schon hart oder? Können wir nicht mithalten. Telefon freaking in best form.
Ja, an den Chaos Computer Club eine Frage, ob die die CD Top Hacker Top Secret kennen?
Ich hab die mal irgendwie bei Saturn liegen sehen, aber glaub ich wollte sie nicht haben.
Na, da sind so paar schöne Files drauf, wo man dann kostenlos telefonieren kann. Also es ist beschrieben, auch mit 0130, wie das gehen soll.
Mit 0130 kannst du immer kostenlos telefonieren.
Da gab es einen schönen Test in der Titanic auch.
Wie ich eine normale Nummer, also ich zum Beispiel nach München mache, und da kostenlos über 0130 telefoniere.
Hast du das mal probiert?
Nee, das geht irgendwie nicht bei uns.
Krass, wie so die CD 0490 kostet.
Jetzt weißt du auch, warum die bei Saturn stehen.
Also ich meine, da ist natürlich da, da tilten natürlich auch das Hackerherz. Eine Hacker CD-ROM bei Saturn, da schließt sich irgendwas gegenseitig aus. Das kann nicht ganz hinhauen, oder? Hacking ist ja doch immer so ein bisschen oder Telefonfreaking, was auch immer, ist ja doch so ein bisschen auf der Grenze zur Illegalität. Deswegen möchten wir euch auch alle davor warnen, irgendwelche Dinge nachzumachen, die Kriminelle euch vormachen. Macht das bitte nicht nach.
Ja, das ist auch beschrieben, wenn man so eine Bluebox baut. Funktioniert das auch?
Na ja, du kannst sicher sein, sobald sowas auf so einer CD veröffentlicht wird, dass das nicht mehr funktioniert.
Geht das nimmer?
Nee, weil in dem Augenblick ist das natürlich allen zugänglich, auch den Leuten, die irgendwie dafür verantwortlich sind, dass eben sowas nicht passiert. Und die unternehmen dann natürlich entsprechende Schritte, um das zu verhindern. Also das funktioniert immer nur solange, solange das in einem kleinen Personenkreis bekannt ist und geheim ist sozusagen.
Ich meine, du hast so eine CD-Rom, warum hast du nicht mal ausprobiert?
Ach na, das ist alles Englisch und also ich mich dort zurecht finde.
Hast du einen Netzanschluss? Nein. Na, sonst hättest du die mal rüber schicken können. Die 620 Megabyte.
Dann wollte ich noch was sagen mit den 0130-Nummern. Also sowas ist mir schlecht. Auch mit dieser ASIA-Nummer habe ich vom Kumpel übers Netz runter. Und also sind sie an die 2000-Nummer, 0130.
Wie und was kommt da?
Was kommt da? Na China, Vereinigt Emiraten, Holland.
Also sowas, was wir gerade gehört haben zum Beispiel.
Ja, und dann noch hier so, wo man dann, ich weiß nicht, so eine 1 drückt und dann geht's dann halt weiter.
Also so...
Voice-Mail.
Multimedia, also Voice-Mail, genau.
Wenn man mal gerade was zu tun hat, ist das okay.
Gut, ich danke dir erstmal.
Bis dann. Also davon kann man glaube ich ausgehen, sobald solche Tricks allzu öffentlich zugänglich sind, kann man davon ausgehen, dass sie nicht mehr funktionieren. Es sind so ein paar Stichwörter... Es sind so ein paar Stichwörter gefallen, nämlich Redbox. Ja, Redbox und Bluebox. Kann man jemand ein bisschen was dazu sagen?
Also Redbox hatten wir ja vorhin schon kurz, also das Simulieren von Münzen in amerikanischen Telefonzellen. Die Simulation, dass man die einwirft durch Töne, was jetzt aber nur noch teilweise funktioniert und auch nur noch für Inlandsgespräche. Und Bluebox ist eben was völlig anderes. Das basiert praktisch darauf, dass sich die internationalen Vermittlungsstellen untereinander, zumindest bei der alten Technik, mit Tönen verständigen. Also die schicken eben Töne von bestimmten Frequenzen hin und her.
Ct5.
C-C-I-T-T-Fünf, genau. Und das sind dann die Töne, die bedeuten zum Beispiel neue Leitung aufbauen und Leitung abbauen und so was alles. Und früher hat das halt ganz prima funktioniert, indem man sozusagen selber Vermittlungsstelle gespielt hat und der Gegenvermittlungsstelle diese Töne da geschickt hat und die hat dann halt dementsprechend darauf reagiert. Und dann konnte man eben weiter wählen und so tun, als sei man selber eine Vermittlungsstelle.
Es gibt auch diese wunderschöne Geschichte von dieser Pfeife in der in der Cap'n Crunch, der sich dann nach dieser nach dieser Complex Packung benannt hat. Vielleicht kann diese Anekdote jemanden noch zum Besten geben?
Ja, also Complex legt immer gerne etwas Plastikspielzeug bei und so war es eine kleine Trillerpfeife, die nicht wirklich trillerte, sondern einfach nur einen konstanten Ton heraus gab und es stellte sich heraus und das hat eben ein Typ erfunden, der später nach dieser Complex Packung mit dem Crunch benannt wurde, dass wenn man in diese Pfeife reinblies, dass sie exakt einen 2600-Hertz-Ton generierte. Dieser 2600-Hertz-Ton in ein Telefon in ein amerikanisches hineingeblasen führte dazu, dass Tobias muss mir kurz weiterhelfen, was umgeschaltet wird.
Na ja, also die hatten da damals noch das alte R1-Signalisierungsverfahren und 2600-Hertz-Ton war halt einfach der Trunk. Also die Leitung wurde praktisch freigegeben. Das war also das Signal für Gespräch beendet. Und dann konnte man eben einfach weiter dialen, also weiter wählen.
Und das war kostenlos.
Das ging dann halt auf Kosten der vorherigen Nummer. Also wenn man vorher irgendwie ein lokales Gespräch gemacht hat, dann hat das auch weiterhin nur lokale Gesprächsgebühren gekostet. Oder wenn man eben eine 1-800-Nummer, also das Gegenstück zu den deutschen 130ern angerufen hat, dann war es eben ganz kostenlos.
Das ist so grundsätzlich das Prinzip des Phone Freakings, auch bei internationalen Verbindungen.
Deswegen ist wahrscheinlich das amerikanische Hacker Magazin auch nach dieser Frequenz benannt.
Genau.
2600, was man im Internet übrigens leicht findet, indem man sich erstmal nur weil die dazugehörigen Newsgroups anguckt. Also einfach mal nach 2600 suchen, einfach die Zahl eingehen.
Oder www.2600.
Wir können ja mal ganz kurz so ein Demo machen, wie sich das so anhört. So ein sogenannter Break, also mit dem man früher ganz einfach eine Vermittlungsstelle davon überzeugen konnte, die Leitung abzubauen und eine neue aufzubauen.
Auf PC oder auf Mac?
PC. Ich hab hier einmal Regler, PC hoch.
Also man hat also eine 130er-Nummer angerufen und sobald die Verbindung dann bestand, oder teilweise auch schon vorher, hat man dann halt den sogenannten Break geschickt. Das sind also zwei Töne. Der erste Ton sagt der gegen der anderen Vermittlungsstelle praktisch Leitung abbauen, Gespräch beendet. Der nächste Ton sagt gleich wieder neue Leitung aufbauen. Und dann kam eben, dann wählt man eben. Das ist eben auch das C5-Wählverfahren. Mit, sind spezielle Töne und da sind dann noch unter anderem Routing Codes mit dabei. Und man sagt eben, ob man ein Transitgespräch führen möchte. Das heißt, das Land, was man gerade sozusagen gebrakt hat, ob man jetzt da bleiben möchte und da lokal jemanden anrufen möchte. Oder ob man das Land als Transitland benutzen möchte und weiter woanders telefonieren.
Zum Beispiel wieder nach.
Das ganze habe ich natürlich nie gemacht, aber ich habe es schon immer gehört.
Und am Telefon ist wer? Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio.
Ja, hier ist der René, hallo.
René, hallo, du hast eine Frage an den Chaos Computer Club.
Ja, genau.
Und zwar geht es darum, ich habe auch ein PC hier mit Modem und habe die Möglichkeit, mich über das Modem an meiner Universität ins Internet einzulocken. Und da ich ja nun mal ein paar Stunden da drinnen herumhänge, fühlt es mich trotzdem auch nachts immer noch ein bisschen teuer. Und da ich mal die Frage habe, ich habe davon gehört, man kann per Modem dort anrufen und dem Modem auf der anderen Seite sagen, dass ich hier auflege und dass es mich sofort zurückruft.
Praktisch, dass ich dann die Gebühren spare.
Geht das überhaupt und wenn, mit welchem Programm?
Ja, das geht natürlich schon, aber das Modem auf der Gegenseite muss dementsprechend konfiguriert sein. Also du kannst jetzt nicht einfach sagen, hallo Modem, ruf mich mal zurück. Sondern es muss halt so eingestellt sein und das muss auf deine Rufnummer wissen. Also bei ESDN ist das ein bisschen was anderes. Bei ESDN werden ja Rufnummern direkt übermittelt. Aber wenn man das mit einem Modem macht, da muss die Gegenstelle deine Rufnummer wissen, das muss so konfiguriert sein und dann geht das. Aber sonst einfach so nicht.
Oder dahin gehen, lernen, wie das geht und das selber machen.
Ja, alles klar.
Wobei wir natürlich den Universitäten, die sowieso von überall sparen müssen jetzt, das ist ja gemein.
Ich glaube, es gab aber Modems, die Zeichsels, die so eine Fähigkeit des Rückrufes sozusagen eingebaut hatten.
Aber da war die Nummer noch besser.
Das muss man natürlich auch konfigurieren.
Außerdem ist das ein Sicherheitsfeature.
Dass man das aber softwaremäßig auf meiner Seite irgendwie macht, geht nicht.
Nein, das geht nicht. Vor allem kurz der Vollständigkeit. Aber die Zeichsels haben dann untereinander auch immer noch ein Passwort abgefragt. Das ging also nicht einfach so, wie Tim das gerade sagte, dass die zurückgerufen haben und alles ist gut. Sondern die Kanten mussten sich untereinander kennen. Die beiden Modem, das musste man auf der Empfängerseite, also der, die die Gebühren übernimmt, so konfigurieren. Das ging also nur, wenn dieses Modem das auch wirklich wollte.
Ja, ein bisschen.
Habt ihr da eine spezielle Adresse, wo man Informationen saugen kann?
www.ccc.de Ach, war ja auch so einfach.
Ja, so einfach.
Das sind natürlich nur die uninteressanten Informationen. Interessante Informationen sind hinter einer wahnsinnig komplizierten URL.
Ja, das wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
Dann kommt man doch irgendwie durch links hin.
Na ja, probier's einfach mal aus, du wirst alles finden, was du willst.
Danke dir. Bis dann, ciao.
Es sind auch einige E-Mails inzwischen eingetroffen. Als erstes eine Beschwerde. Es gibt eine Beschwerde von jemandem. Zu Recht müssen wir sagen. Halli, hallo, fängt sie an. Ich, 27, studie, höre gerade eure Telefonspaßsendung und bin strikt dagegen, die arme Telekom zu ärgern. Insbesondere finde ich es sehr schlimm, wenn Telefonrechnungen mit Überweisungen beglichen werden, bei denen als Überweisungsempfänger anstatt Telekom böse Wörter wie teuer kommen oder terror kommen eingetragen sind. Dies kränkt die fleißigen Ex-Postler umso mehr, als sie die Herstellung von T-Shirts mit dem Aufdruck Terrorkomm verbieten ließen. Dennoch ist mir bekannt, dass es Mitmenschen gibt, die solche Überweisungen tätigen. Ich möchte mich an dieser Stelle von derartigen Schämereien distanzieren, da sie nicht nett sind.
Bussi, euer Peter.
Kleine Beschwerde, da muss man mit leben können, Jungs. Kritik muss man er tragen. Das hier ist wahrscheinlich eine E-Mail von jemandem, wahrscheinlich von dem, der umsonst telefoniert hat. Das Telefon macht tut, steht da drin. Das ist sehr schön.
Er hat zumindest schon mal die Basis Technologie begriffen.
Hallo ihr Chaoten ist eine E-Mail von Axel. Mein Beitrag zu eurem heutigen Thema. Erzählt doch mal den Herrn, dass man sich zum Beispiel zu Testzwecken selbst über die... Mann ey, das mit dem Austausch immer klappt noch nicht richtig mit den ASCII Codes. Dass man sich zu Test...
Oder er schreibt total schlecht.
Testzwecken selbst über die digitale Vermittlungsstelle zurückrufen lassen kann. Hier in Dresden zum Beispiel 117755 und Rufnummer. Nach einer Minute ruft es zurück. Ich verwende das auf und zu selber auf Arbeit.
Vielleicht ist es euch erwähnenswert.
Chao Axel. Das ist ein netter Partygag. Also es gibt so Nummern für Telekom Mitarbeiter, dass sie checken können, ob die Leitung steht. Dann man hebt hier den Hörer ab, wählt eine Nummer und danach die Rufnummer, an der man sich gerade befindet.
Und dann ruft es nach einer Minute auch hier zur Wahrheitsfindung. Gleichzeitig prüft die Vermittlungsstelle die Qualität der Leitung. Das heißt, die Leitung wird durchgemessen und zu diesem Vorgang ein Protokoll erstellt. Das heißt, jeder, der das macht, ist dann auch hinterher amtlich erfasst. Das sollte man dazu sagen. Das ist nicht wirklich gefährlich oder so irgendwas. Aber auf Dauer werden die das nicht mögen, glaube ich.
Also kurz nach der Rende gab es eine Nummer auch in Ostberlin. Und damit haben wir mal Leute geargert, die mir erzählt haben, wenn du diese Nummer eingibst und dann nach deiner Nummer und dein Telefon klingelt, dann ist dein Anschluss verwanzt. Es gab Leute, die haben es tatsächlich wirklich geglaubt, das wurde danach so ein bisschen paradoxisch.
Das sind halt wirklich Testnummern von der Telekom. Die gibt es sowohl bei Analogen als auch bei digitalen Vermittlungsstellen. Funktionieren aber grundsätzlich unterschiedlich. Die Nummern sind ungefähr immer gleich. Also immer was mit 011 77 55 oder 555 oder 455 oder sowas. Und dann die eigene Nummer.
Das dauert ja dann nicht lange, bis man die raushält.
Und bei Analogenvermittlungsstellen ruft das Teil dann halt zurück und man kriegt so einen Piepton zu hören. Und dann kann man da noch so ein paar Tests machen. Danach kann man dann die sogenannte Blasprobe machen. Das heißt, man prüft mit in den Hörer. Und dann kriegt man eine automatisierte Ansage, wieviel Promille man hat. Nein, in Wirklichkeit kommt dann, wenn das halt angekommen ist, auf der anderen Seite wieder ein Piepton. Und als nächstes muss man dann mit Pulswahl eine Null wählen. Dann kommt wieder ein Piepton und dann ist der Test sozusagen abgeschlossen. Und bei digitalen Vermittlungsstellen, da gibt es teilweise richtige Menüs. Also das ruft einen dann zurück. Und man hat dann da so die unterschiedlichsten Testoptionen. Man kann sich Gebührenimpulse schicken lassen, die nicht gezählt werden. Und irgendwie man kann die Touchtöne von seinem Telefon testen, ob die auch richtig rüberkommen und sowas alles.
Es gibt eine andere E-Mail von Rup Sascha, der hat das gerade mit der Bluebox gehört und fragt, wo man die Frequenztabellen für dieses wunderschöne Programm herkriegt.
Na im Internet.
Wo ungefähr?
Das ist leider so, dass das nicht mehr so funktioniert. Also so einfach wie wir das eben demonstriert haben. Das war wirklich mal ganz früher, als hier in Deutschland gerade die 130er eingeführt wurden. Also ich glaube 1989 oder so war das. Das funktioniert jetzt, wenn überhaupt, dann nur noch sehr, sehr viel komplizierter. Und mit mehr Tönen und mit anderen Tönen und so weiter. Und das können nur noch sehr, sehr wenige Leute. Und es gibt eigentlich außer Selbstausprobieren kaum eine Möglichkeit daran zu kommen.
Aber du hast so ein schönes Programm auf dem PC irgendwie. Ich weiß keine Ahnung wofür es ist, aber...
So ein Programm, das Programm zu kriegen, ist kein Problem. Aber mit dem Programm an sich kann man nichts anstellen. Ich meine da kann man irgendwie ein bisschen rumspielen.
Das Problem ist halt, dass man immer mehr Vermittlungsstellen hat, auch neue Technologie updaten und da halt irgendwie nicht mehr die Signale innerhalb des Telefonkanals, in dem man noch spricht, übertragen, sondern außerhalb. Und da hat man halt ein Problem da irgendwie zu spielen.
Also, es gibt da...
Warte ganz kurz, kann man sagen, wo man dieses... Wie heißt das Programm?
Das ging dann...
Es gab eine Einrichtung wie auch diese Rückrufnummern zum Testen von neu einzurichtenden Anschlüssen. Und der Telekom-Techniker machte das dann so, dass er mit einem speziellen Telefon, mit einer Wählscheibe, eine vollständige Nummer wählte zum Testen, um aber keine Gebühren aufkommen zu lassen, wählte er anstatt der Null, am Anfang der Vorwahl, eine sogenannte 11. Also nicht 10 Impulse, sondern eben 11 Impulse.
Und ansonsten die ganz normale Nummer.
Und dann war das genau das gleiche Gespräch, bloß eben kostenlos.
Ich hab's selbst ausprobiert.
Irgendwann haben sie es dann abgeschaltet.
Ja, das funktionierte auch prima, indem man im 20 Millisekunden Takt auf die Gabel haute bei den alten Telefonen ging.
Das hab ich ja auch gemacht, weil ich hatte kein Telefon mit.
Was ja jeder so im rechten Handgelenk hat.
Zumindest die Jungs.
Ja, das ging dann übrigens damals mit den Telefonzellen auch. Da gab's dann noch einen anderen Trick, den auch kurz noch, das geht mittlerweile auch nicht mehr. Da konnte man, die Telefonzellen waren mit vier Kabeln angeschlossen. Das ging in Amerika noch sehr viel länger. Da konnte man die Leitungen auftrennen und zwei, wenn man wusste welche, die zwei von diesen Kabeln kurz schließen, dann hat er die Pulse nicht mehr durchgeschickt, hat aber trotzdem akzeptiert, dass alles richtig ist. Man hat einmal Münzen eingeschmissen und konnte damit beliebig lange telefonieren. Am Schluss kamen die Münzen wieder raus.
Am Mikrofon hörte uns ein Moderator, der sich ärgert, dass er die vorhin sitzenden Leute nicht ungefähr 15 Jahre kennenlernte.
Was auch noch sehr gut funktionierte, war von Taxiständen aus dieses Puls wählen mit der Hand. Wer da einigermaßen Übung drin hatte, konnte da auch sehr günstig.
Ach, von dem Telefon am Taxistand?
Ja, da war meistens keine W-Scheibe dran oder die war vernietet oder wie auch immer. Und wer da einigermaßes Geschick hatte in den Händen, der konnte da gut sparen.
Das ist so eine Idee.
Fällt auch nicht auf, wenn man an der Taxisäule steht und sagt, ja Mama, ich komme heute ein bisschen später.
Wir müssen an diesem Punkt mal unterscheiden, worüber wir hier reden. Das sind, ich will mal so ein bisschen zu den moralischen Komponenten. Ich denke, bei sowas muss man immer sehr genau drauf achten, ob man dabei jemandem wehtut, sprich, ob man jemandem schadet, ob man auf Kosten von jemand anderem telefoniert oder ob das jetzt eigentlich niemanden wirklich etwas kostet. Man stelle sich vor, jetzt eine Ortsverbindung, da benutzt man Leitungen, da entstehen jetzt niemanden wirklich Kosten, wenn man die Telekom-Abrechnung umgeht. Das ist eine Sache. Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel solche Dinge tut, wie im Internet gibt es öfter mal Serien von Kreditkartennummern. Wenn man jetzt also eine solche Kreditkartennummer benutzt, um damit zu telefonieren, das ist eine echte Frechheit, weil da muss irgendjemand anderes für bezahlen. Das ist selbstverständlich nicht in Ordnung. Da gibt es einen gehörigen Unterschied, ob man jemandem dabei schadet, mit dem was man da tut, oder ob man nur einen virtuellen Schaden erzeugt dabei.
Mit anderen Worten, Telefonfreaking okay, solange es niemanden wirklich schadet. Da höre ich einen moralischen Aspekt raus, den aber der CCC sowieso hat, oder? Wobei es gibt ja auch so eine Hackerregeln und so, nicht nur jetzt von euch, sondern der Allgemeine. Es gibt eine Ethik, es gibt ja auch eine Etikett, die man wahrscheinlich langsam vergessen kann. Na ja, wenn man sich die Newsclubs so anguckt, dann kennen sie höchstens 30%.
Das war aber auch noch nie anders.
Nein.
Aber zumindest von, na egal.
Wenn halt mehr Leute im Netz sind, gibt es halt auch Idioten. Also es ist einfach eine Prozentfrage so. Diese Sache, mit die man schaden oder nicht schaden, ist halt irgendwie eine lange Diskussion. Weil es gibt halt natürlich auch Leute, die argumentieren, na ja, wenn man auf einer Kreditkarte richtig holzt, dann ist da so viel passiert, dass die Kreditkartengesellschaft demjenigen jetzt wahrscheinlich gar nicht in Rechnung stellen, weil klar ist, dass es sich dabei nicht um eine normale Buchung handeln kann. Andererseits ist es so, dass manche Kreditkartengesellschaften spielen halt Schweine und sagen, ok, ist deine Kreditkarte, du zahlst heute mit weissen Halten.
Außerdem muss ich da jetzt mal unterbrechen. Dann muss selbstverständlich die Kreditkartengesellschaft, der Telekom, das Geld dafür bezahlen. Damit haben wir also einen eindeutigen Geschädigten. Das kann man gut oder schlecht finden, ist eine ganz andere Frage. Aber in diese Ethik passt das natürlich nicht. Die Telekom wird insofern ja nicht geschädigt, als dass sie nur ihr Geld dafür nicht bekommt. Dass sie dafür gerne in Rechnungen stellen würde, dabei aber selbst eigentlich keine weiteren Unkosten dadurch hat, dass diese Verbindung ausgebaut würde. Es sei denn, man telefoniert ins Ausland. Dann muss die Telekom halt an andere ausländische Telefongesellschaften Geld abdrücken dafür, dass du kostenlos telefoniert hast.
Man muss dazu vielleicht mal sagen, nicht dass ihr der Eindruck entsteht, dass Phone Freaking nur darum geht, kostenlos zu telefonieren. Phone Freaking ist halt allgemein eben Spaß mit dem Telefon. Kostenlos telefonieren ist unter anderem ein Effekt, der dabei abfällt. Da ist es eben wirklich ein Unterschied. Wenn man sich bei jemandem auf die Leitung draufklemmt und dann auf dessen Kosten telefoniert, dann ist es nicht mehr lustig, weil das macht dem richtig viel Ärger. Das ist eigentlich auch nicht Freaking, weil da hat man nicht irgendwie toll was rausgefunden oder muss man sich nicht groß Mühe geben, muss man einfach nur dreist sein und irgendwie in den Keller gehen und da irgendwie Kabel umklemmen.
Das ist dann Asching.
Wir reden über witzige Sachen, die man mit dem Telefon machen kann. Wir haben schon einige davon gehört hier im Chaos Radio. Also reißt euch ein bisschen zusammen. Es ist nicht witzig, wenn ihr euren besten Freunden Telefonrechnungen in mehreren tausend Mark, in der Höhe von mehreren tausend Mark aufbrummt, sondern witzig ist, sind andere Sachen. Ihr könnt uns hier erreichen unter chaos.org.de Das ist die E-Mailer.
rübergehend nicht erreichbar.
Doch. Und zwar unter 0331 für Potsdam 748110. Mal gucken, was so gerade noch am Telefon rumhängt. Hallo, wer ist da?
Hier ist Chaos Radio. Hallo.
Ah, du bist so leise.
Ja, ich bin, es ist ziemlich leise.
Ich verstehe auch nicht alles, aber ich hätte bloß noch eine kurze Frage. Ich habe gehört von jemandem, dass ein Telekom-Monteur als Service, also wo er das kontribuiert hat, eine Nummer angerufen hat, hat aufgelegt und nach ein paar, sagen wir mal, zehn Sekunden oder wie hat das Telefon nur geläutet.
Ja, das haben wir, waren wir gerade vor zehn Minuten bei dem Thema, das gibt's ja. Also es gibt eine Nummer von der Telekom, ich kann dir sagen, wie sie in Dresden heißt. Warte mal kurz.
Das war die 11-77-55, das gilt aber auch nicht für ganz Dresden, das gilt dann halt nur für Vermittlungsstellen.
Kannst du die Straßen noch sagen bitte?
Ja klar, dann glaub ich.
Also in Dresden zum Beispiel funktioniert das mit der 11-77-55 und dann deine eigene Rufnummer, jeder der in Dresden. 11-77-55, 11-77.
Das ist in Winterstadt unterschiedlich.
Das ist in Winterstadt wahrscheinlich unterschiedlich, ja.
Ja, also es kommt immer darauf an, es ist ungefähr immer so das gleiche. Also meistens irgendwas mit 011-77-55 und dann die eigene Nummer einfach mal ausprobieren.
Wir müssen jetzt das Gewinnspiel mal wieder ein bisschen in Gang bringen.
Ja, ich danke dir erstmal.
Bis dann.
Oliwans klingeln jetzt hier die Leitungen heiß. Deswegen mal kurz gucken, was passiert.
Wir machen aber...
Oder haben wir so viele Anrufe?
Na, es sind ziemlich viele Anrufe.
Lass mal checken. Lass mal checken, klingt cool. Alter, Musik drunter und mal checken.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Chaos Radio hier. Sacher.
Hallo? Hi, wer bist du denn?
Äh, ich hab zwar nicht viel Ahnung von dem Zeug, aber... Ich hab mal eine Telefonzelle gehabt. Die hatte ich abgezogen. Die Telefonkarte hab ich abgezogen.
Wie?
Erzähl doch mal. Du bist schwer zu verstehen. Sag doch mal.
Ich hatte mal eine Telefonzelle gefunden. Und von der hab ich mal angerufen und die hat mir die Telefonkarte abgezogen.
Ach, also du hast eine Telefonkarte reingetan, aber die Summe hat sich nicht verändert. Ah, da guck ich mal in die Runde. Alles grinst und nickt. Ja, da siehst du mal, es geht gar nicht darum, irgendwelche Ahnung zu haben. Es geht manchmal darum, einfach Glück zu haben. Das hat ein Vierteljahr lang funktioniert.
Ja, und dann haben wir so ein bisschen repariert worden.
Schade.
Dann fährt man ruhig mal 5 Minuten mit dem Auto, ne?
Ja, allerdings, dann ärgert man sich allerdings, dass man so wenig Leute in Hongkong kennt.
Der ESPN-Anschluss, der kommt jetzt genügt im Januar.
Da fällt mir ein zu dem Thema kostenlos telefonieren. Früher war es immer so, bis vor einem Jahr ungefähr, wenn man im Ausbildung immer rumgeguckt hat, vor welchen Telefonzellen die längsten Schlangen waren, von irgendwelchen Asylbewerbern oder so, dann konnte man immer sehr genau feststellen, wo jetzt gerade telefonieren kostenlos ging, weil die haben es irgendwie am schnellsten rausbekommen.
Ja, ich glaube, man nennt das aus der Not eine Tugend machen sozusagen. Übrigens, in dem Zusammenhang, es ist ganz gut, dass du das gesagt hast, ich hab keine Ahnung, aber ich weiß, dass es viele Leute gibt, die das ein bisschen abschreckt, dass der Chaos Computer Club hier sitzt und die haben alle Ahnung und erzählen und werfen Fachbegriffe durcheinander. Habt keine Angst hier irgendwie anzurufen mit dümmlichen Fragen oder so oder mit zum Beispiel witzigen Geschichten, wie die in drei, vier, vierhundert Jahren schön umsonst von Telefonzellen angerufen. Das geht nicht darum, dass irgendjemand, dass alle den super Durchblick haben. Alter, nicht jeder so für Zeit wie ihr, ne?
Von, wir haben jetzt andere Leute sehen, jetzt schon mit den Telefonpiraten. Das war natürlich eine schlimme Sache gewesen, fand ich.
Telefonpiraten?
Ja, wenn du jetzt so ein unlöses Telefon hast, so eine Kette 300 Meter Reichweite und da wohnt einer in der Straße, dasselbe Telefon von der selben Marktdose, so mit einer zirklischen Fabrikat oder so und der hat dann Hörer nicht auf das Gerät gelegt und ist dann in die Straße gegangen und hieß dann auf den Analog-Anzeiger mit Freizeit, dann kannst du über seinen Apparat, über seine Feststation, also auf telefonieren.
Ja, aber da haben wir es wieder, ne? Da muss ja jemand für blechen, nämlich irgendjemand, den du gar nicht kennst und der vielleicht echt nur ein paar Mark hat.
Das war dann doch wirklich die Dummheit der Leute, weil das waren alles zum zugelassene Telefone.
Oh, hier klingelt eine Nummer, das kann nicht sein.
Das sind unzugelassene Telefone, da gibt es ein lustiges Darum.
Das kann nicht sein, ey.
Da hat jemand angerufen und aufgelegt.
Der wusste es.
Das rote Telefon hat geklingelt.
Die hat mir jemand erzählt und zwar mit so unzugelassene Telefone, da gab es irgendwo eine Geschichte, da hat jemanden ja auch so ein Ding gehabt, irgendwie mit mehreren Kilometer Reichweite und das war... Ja, das war wohl irgendwie eher so noch die geboostete Wende und die war dann zufällig auf dem Tonkanal irgendwie vom Fernsehprogramm und der hat sich dann natürlich mit seiner Freundin gefetzt und kam irgendwie nach Hause und war im südlichen Land über Spanien oder so und irgendwie das halbe Dorf stand dann irgendwie da auf der Straße und klatschte irgendwie, weil das ihr richtig gegeben habt, dass ihr alle im Fernsehen zugehört habt.
Frank, das ist nicht lustig.
Ich sag, wie heißt du nochmal?
Christian, ich sag dir schon mal Tschüss.
Tschüss. Tschau, um deine Telefonkosten zu sparen, das war eine schlechte Leitung, dafür kann aber Christian nichts. Die anderen Leute im Moment laufen die Leitung, bleibt ein bisschen dran. Habt die Ausdauer?
Hallo, wer ist da?
Chaosradio hier, hallo.
Hallo.
Ich hab mal eine Frage.
Der Johnny hat gesagt, da können auch die anrufen, die absolut keine Ahnung haben vom Telefon. Und zwar, ich hab hier ein Fax-Feriengeschenk bekommen und das läuft bei mir über die Telefonleitung. Über die, nein, über die Telefonleitung.
Und da ist noch die alte Kennung eingegeben.
Habt ihr da eine Ahnung, wie ich die da rauskriegen kann? Weil immer, wenn ich hier mache, Daten eingeben, Gesundheit ändern.
Da hängt schwer von dem Gerät ab, was du hast.
Ja und zwar guck in die zweite Hand. Da ist ständig unter Rubrik Fax eine Annonce drin. In Hamburg annunciert da jemand oder der 04.0. Jahr Telefonnummer. Er hat sämtliche Anleitungen, wie man Fax-Nummern programmiert, also die ID. Und schickt die irgendwie für 30 Markigen Nachname zu.
Ach so.
Also da muss man aufpassen. Es gibt für manche Fax-Geräte so lustige Sachen. Da muss man ein ganz bestimmtes Fax durchtüdeln, dass ein bestimmtes Muster auf dem Papier hat, dass man überhaupt in diesen Operator Mode kommt, um dann bestimmte Sachen einzustellen. Aber die Kennung kann man dann meistens auch über Tastenkombination einstellen.
Sowas passiert aber übrigens nicht nur, wenn man, ich kenne das Problem, das passiert einem nicht nur, wenn man jetzt, weiß nicht, gebrauchten Gerät oder ein Geschenk das kriegt oder so, sondern auch wenn man einfach eins kauft, was ein bisschen älter ist, dann hat man keine Ahnung, wie man da die Kennung einstellt. Kann man nicht einfach auch bei der Firma anrufen?
Also 30 Mark ist ja nicht gerade billig.
Ja, und also Firmen anrufen ist halt meistens auch nicht billiger, ne?
Außerdem gibt es Leute, die möchten einfach partout nicht die Firma anrufen. Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Was ist denn, also wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, du hast das Gerät ganz legal erworben.
Kannst du die Firma sagen?
Alcatel Fax 35.
Vielleicht gibt es ja jemanden, der jetzt zuhört und da einen Tipp hat.
Alcatel Fax 35, wer weiß, wie man die Kennung eingibt, der oder die kann hier anrufen.
Und ansonsten kannst du an der zweiten Hand gucken, ob du da Erfolg hast. Da ist ein Problem, Fakt, Kennung ändern. Falls ihr noch Fragen habt, könnt ihr anrufen. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Hallo, hier ist der Martin.
Martin, hi.
Hallöchen, ich wollte etwas lustiges erzählen.
Also, das war zur Ostzeit noch und da hab ich mit meinen, wir hatten noch kein Telefon und da war ich mit meiner Mutter in der Telefonzelle und da kam das Geld nicht wieder raus nach dem Anruf und da habe ich dann vor lauter Wut so drauf gedonnert, da hat es klick, klack, klack gemacht und da war der ganze Apparat unten voll, war leider kein Geld drin, nur die Glühbohnen, die waren komplett voll, die waren diese grauen Plastikapparate, ne? Ja genau, hat sich dann ausgesorgt, hab es heute noch welche.
Also, eine der witzigen Sachen, die man mit dem Telefon anstellen kann, die wir am Anfang nicht überhaupt gestellt haben, aber einmal hin.
Ja, kam auf die Schlachtkräftigkeit an.
Diese grauen Plastiktelefone, die man sowieso geliebt hat, da man da auch Markstücke an Amel-Seene hinein lassen konnte. Das ging im Westen aber auch.
Deswegen haben sie ja diese Schieber immer reingemacht, dass man die nicht wieder rausfummeln kann.
Jetzt weiß ich, was man unter West-Konflikt versteht.
Das ging im Westen auch.
Ja, das war eine schöne Geschichte, ich dank dir.
Hi, Chaosradio hier.
Hallo, welche Sendung?
Ja, Peter, aber ich wollte auch was lustiges erzählen. Und zwar, ich brauch keine Ahnung von Telefon, deswegen wollte ich euch mal fragen. Ich hab meinen Freund angerufen und der Anrufsbeantworter war dran. Hab ich halt meine Nachricht hinterlassen, dass ich mich mit ihm treffen wollte. Aber hab vermutet, dass er fängt oder so. Und hab gleich danach nochmal angerufen, kam wieder der Anrufsbeantworter und da hat er mich genervt, würde ich nicht nochmal das gleiche sagen. Hab aufgelegt und nach ein paar Sekunden hat es bei mir geklingelt. Ich hab abgenommen, hab nichts gehört. Dann hab ich gedacht, das ist irgendein Idiot oder so, der will mir anrufen. Hab gesagt, hallo, hallo, hallo. Hab aufgelegt und weil ich beim Telefon war, wieder mein Freund angerufen, kam wieder der Anrufsbeantworter, hab mich wieder aufgelegt. Das gleiche nochmal, hat mich wieder jemand angerufen und war wieder das gleiche. Ich dachte mir, dass da irgendjemand war und wollte mich ärgern. Und so nahe hab ich gesagt, na ist ja witzig. Jetzt fang ich mal an, den voll zu schimpfen. Und hab erstmal losgelegt, ja du Bilderperversie, was soll es bei mir anzurufen, aber es macht mir gar nichts.
Und das war dann bei ihm das Anrufsbeantworter.
Ich muss zu schwach sein, aber auf einmal kam in der Grund die Stimme von der Mutter von ihm, vielen Dank für Ihren Anruf.
Das war Anfang des Jahres, da wollte die Telekom eigentlich mal was Gutes tun.
Wer hat die neuen Tarife geholt und so was?
Genau, der Mehrwertservice. Und die wollten an sämtlichen digitalen Vermittlungsstellen die neuen Leistungsnachmale anklopfen, rückfragen, makeln und Dreierkonferenz freischalten. Das haben sie dann auch teilweise gemacht. Und zwar ist das so eine Sache, da kannst du dann bei einem ganz normalen Telefonanschluss irgendwie während du schon mit jemandem telefonierst noch jemand anders anrufen und den anderen in so eine Art Warteschleife packen. Und es kann noch ein zweiter Anruf reinkommen, während du bereits telefonierst. Da ist dann halt so ein Ton in der Leitung. Dann kannst du den Anruf annehmen. Und dann kannst du sogar eine Dreierkonferenz machen. Also dann beide zusammenschalten. Damit kann man zu dritt telefonieren. Und das hat die Telekom eben einfach für alle freigeschaltet. Aber ohne alle Leute darüber zu informieren, dass das jetzt so ist. Und da ist dann einfach das Folgendes passiert. Du hast also bei dem Anrufbeantworter angerufen. Hast dann hinterher aufgelegt, hast aber kürzer als eine Sekunde aufgelegt. Und hast die Gabel dann sofort wieder losgelassen. Und das hatte dann zur Folge, dass die erste Verbindung zum Anrufbeantworter nicht zu Ende war, sondern dass du die sozusagen nur in die Warteschleife gepackt hast. So, dann hast du wieder ein W-Zeichen und dachtest alles ist okay. Das war jetzt aber eigentlich schon dein zweites Gespräch, was du angefangen hast. So und als du dann das zweite Mal den Anrufbeantworter angerufen hast und aufgelegt hast, dann war sozusagen das erste Gespräch die ganze Zeit noch im Hintergrund. Und um darauf aufmerksam zu machen, dass das erste Gespräch noch da ist, wenn du aufgelegt hast, klingelt dann halt wieder das Telefon. So und da hast du dann halt abgenommen und hattest dir das erste Gespräch dran, ohne davon zu wissen.
Dabei entstehen natürlich Telefonkosten und die Telekom erstattet dir diese Kosten pauschal zurück, wenn du das bekundest, dass dir das so passiert ist.
Aber es war relativ teilig, weil ich dann danach nochmal die Eltern angerufen hab und denen irgendwie erklären musste, weil die kannten mich dann. Die haben sich voll gewundert. Als erstes an Anrufsbeantworter war immer so eine Stimme.
Hallo, hallo, hallo.
Ich bin jetzt der VAT, ich weiß ganz genau, wer ihr seid.
Also eigentlich ist das eine recht schicke Sache, mit diesem neuen Leistungsnachmachen, dass die Telekom hätte irgendwie mal sämtliche Leute darüber informieren müssen. Da gab es dann halt solche Proteste deswegen, dass es dann irgendwie nach zwei, drei Wochen alles wieder abgeschaltet wurde. Inzwischen kann man sich das wieder kostenlos freischalten lassen. Muss man der Telekom allerdings schriftlich geben, dass man das haben will, dass man sich hinterher nicht beschweren kann.
Das Telekom was schriftlich zu geben ist überall ganz passiert. Eigene Erfahrungen in den letzten drei Monaten war sehr, sehr schwierig.
Und apropos im Telefonieren im Osten. Damals fand ich es auch ganz witzig, da war ich noch ziemlich jung und da gab es ein Telefon und da brauchte man Geld einstecken oder nicht. Das hat einfach immer funktioniert in so einer Telefonzelle. Aber das haben sie jetzt zwar irgendwie morgen noch in der Straße, aber jetzt weg irgendwie.
Am Cihonskirchplatz war so ein Ding, das ging durch vier Jahre, oder? Das war echt unglaublich. Irgendwann war das Schlagge davor.
Aber heute noch zahlreiche Telefone so quer über die ganze Stadt verteilt, die in irgendeinem Grund noch nicht totgeschaltet werden.
Es gibt auch einen Tipp für alle, die moralisch was auf sich halten.
Wenn ihr solche Telefonzellen entdeckt, bitte ruft nicht bei der Telekom an, um zu sagen, dass da was nicht stimmt.
Genau, aber falls ihr mit dem neuen Leistungsmerkmal Probleme hattet und euch dadurch Kosten entstanden sind, dann solltet ihr euch natürlich auf jeden Fall an die Telekom wenden, denn ich nehme an, dass es euch allen passiert.
Da gibt es unheimliche Leute, denen das passiert ist, und wenn euch dadurch Kosten entstanden sind, Zwinker, Zwinker!
Okay, Peter, ich danke dir. Bis dann, ciao.
Davon hat der ja sonst nie was gehört, dass man von diesen Merkmalen eben nichts weiß und dann so eine Geschichte passieren wie Rückruf der noch bestehenden Leitung.
Wenn ihr Beschwerden bei der Telekom habt, wie macht ihr das schriftlich oder?
Alain, du kannst du vergessen.
Sie fahren ihre Computer runter.
Mir soll es recht sein, sie buchen bei mir. Sie schicken mir eine Rechnung nach der anderen, aber das Geld haben sie noch nicht, weil sie haben sich da total vertan mit der Rechnung. Ich habe sie da bestimmt 12 oder 15 Mal darauf hingewiesen.
Telefonisch ist mir das bis jetzt nicht wirklich geglückt.
Ich mache mal folgenden Trick. Ich nehme die Nummer, die jetzt auf dem Brief drauf steht und dann modifiziere ich die letzten beiden Stellen, solange sich irgendjemand an der Strippe habe und dem sage ich dann, ich möchte bitte verbunden werden. Das hat bis jetzt immer ganz gut geklappt. Mittlerweile geht auch das nicht mehr, habe ich den Eindruck. Ich glaube, die legen alle irgendwie den Hörer daneben oder keine Ahnung. Es ist mir bis jetzt also nicht mehr gelungen, da anzurufen. Mir soll es recht sein, bei mir liegt das Geld auf der Bank und macht für mich Zinsen, bei denen wäre es andersrum. Also warte ich, bis sie mir das Telefon abstellen, dann mache ich richtig Rabatt.
Typisch übrigens hat der Telekom was faxt, achtet unbedingt darauf, dass ihr irgendwie in so ein Journal eingeschaltet habt bei euch. Das hat also im Zweifelsfalle nachweisbar ist, dass ihr einen Fax rausgeschickt habt.
Also einschreiben funktioniert auch immer ganz gut.
Man sollte immer, wenn man einen Fax schickt, man sollte erst einen Fax schicken und dann irgendwie parallel noch ein Einschreiben los schicken. Dann ist man wenigstens sicher, dass es angekommen ist. Wenn man irgendwelche Beschwerden an die Telekom hat, ist es sowieso das Beste irgendwie da schriftlich vorzugehen, denn irgendwie telefonisch selbst, wenn man jemanden erreicht, geht das dann meistens irgendwie verloren.
Allerdings, wenn ich jetzt jemanden mal hatte, war der Telekom, dann waren sie echt immer furchtbar nett. Soviel muss ich da doch denn auch mal sagen.
Das ist mir jetzt auch schon passiert.
Die haben irgendwie ziemlich viele Leute auf Schulung geschickt, damit sie zur Aktien-Einschulung auch irgendwie halbwegs Kundenkompetent sind.
Ich kann ja mal wirklich mal sagen, wir sind freundlicher geworden.
Ich hab noch nie so freundlich gehört, dass sie mir nicht essen können.
Ich kann ja mal ganz kurz sagen, was die Telekom für eher geizige Ziele hat bis 1998. Also wenn dann irgendwie der Wettbewerb losgeht, wie das dann alles sein soll, dann wird ein Telefonanschluss, also wenn man irgendwie eine Wohnung einzieht, wo es vorher schon einen Telefonanschluss gab und der muss nur noch wieder freigeschaltet werden, dann soll man bei der Telekom anrufen und der wird dann angeblich innerhalb von 10 Minuten wieder freigeschaltet. Und neuen Telefonanschluss soll es innerhalb von 24 Stunden geben.
Angeblich.
Das wäre einer der Bereiche, in dem ich gerne eine amerikanische Verhältnisse hätte.
Hallo, hier Chaos Radio.
Hallo.
Hi, du bist dran.
Ja, ich heiße Stefan. Ich habe eine Frage, kann man diese Nummerübermittlung bei ausgehenden Anrufen auch abschalten? Ich habe bei der Telekom ausdrücklich mehrmals gesagt, die sollen das nicht machen. Also die sollen meine Nummer nicht mit übermitteln, wenn ich nur anrufe. Aber das passiert einfach trotzdem. Was haben wir denn für einen Anschluss?
Mehrgeräteanschluss.
Also solltest du das vielleicht schriftlich machen. Es gibt da zwei Unterschiede. Einmal gibt es irgendwie die komplette Unterdrückung der Rufnummer, die ständige Unterdrückung. Das heißt also es gehen gar keine, die Rufnummer geht überhaupt nicht mehr raus. Das kostet auch nichts. Also da musst du bloß irgendwie schriftlich ein Brief hinschicken oder so was und dann nochmal anrufen und ein bisschen Stress machen und so. Also dann sollte das eigentlich funktionieren. Das kostet nichts. Dann geht wie gesagt gar keine Rufnummer mehr raus. Dann gibt es noch die Fallweise Rufnummer Unterdrückung. Da musst du dann das Flag setzen. Also ist jetzt die Frage, ob du eben Voice raus telefonierst, also normal telefonierst, oder halt einen Datencall machst. Die meisten Telefone haben eben die Möglichkeit das zu sagen, kannst Rufnummer unterdrücken. Wenn du eben die Fallweise Rufnummer Unterdrückung freigeschaltet hast, und du sagst bei deinem Telefon Rufnummer unterdrücken, dann wird die eben auch nicht mit übermittelt. Aber du kannst dann eben Fallweise unterscheiden, ob sie übermittelt werden soll oder nicht. Das kostet pro B-Kanal 1, 50 Euro im Monat, da man das nur für beide B-Kanäle freischalten lassen kann, also 3 Mark im Monat.
Achso, geht das dann auch mit Modem oder nur mit normalen Telefonen? Ich hab da nur Modems dran eigentlich.
Modems oder ESDN-Karten?
Nee, Zürchsel, also so richtige externe Modems eben.
Das kommt dann, wo hast du die dann dranhängen am ESDN-Anschluss?
Ich hab den NTWA in meinem Zimmer, diesen grauen Karten, da hab ich die beiden Modems dran, an den beiden Dosen, sozusagen genau vollgelegt. Die ESDN-Zürchsel, ja?
Jaja, genau.
Ja, das weiß ich nicht, also ich kenn mich mit denen jetzt nicht so genau aus. Da müsstest du mal nachgucken in der Anleitung, ob da irgendwas von drin steht, von fallweise Rufen und Unterdrückung oder so.
Die Anleitung ist ein Witz, die ist englisch und nicht mal vollständig. Kannst du glaub ich vergessen bei den Dingern, aber das muss halt dort als explizit unterstützt worden sein.
Also da müsstest du dann vielleicht wirklich irgendwie ständige Rufen und Unterdrückung beantworten.
Das ist doch echt doof, ich hab das schon zweimal bei der Telekom gemacht und auch bei der Bestellung des Anschlusses auch.
Du solltest dich vielleicht besser an einen Zürchsel wenden, weil erstens kannst du deine Firmware bei einem Zürchsel austauschen und zweitens denke ich, dass sie das sehr viel schneller ändern können, als die Telekom, die das richtig freischaltet.
Moment, du kannst aber nicht die Rufnummern unterdrücken, wenn die Telekom das nicht freigeschaltet hat.
Ja, aber wenn es freigeschaltet ist, kann dein Modem es eben fallweise bereitstellen oder nicht, weil manchmal ist es ja auch nötig, dass man diese Rufnummern Anzeige hat, wenn man sich zum Beispiel bei sicheren ESDN-Ports einlegt.
Also üblicherweise hilft das per Einschreiben zu schicken und dabei zu erwähnen, dass das rechtsbewehrt wäre, wenn wir das nicht tun, weil es dann gegen das Datenschutzgesetz verstößt, wenn sie die Rufnummer gegen deinen Willen doch weiterzuschicken.
Na gut, dann werde ich das mal probieren.
Da wird im Telefonbuch gesagt, da haben sie mich auch zuerst eintragen wollen.
Da muss ich dann auch wieder mehrmals meckern.
Ist das nicht wahr?
Ich habe vorhin schon vor der Sendung ein bisschen geredet.
Kommt vor. Und ich habe einen Kommt-vor-Anschlag.
Da haben wir beschlossen, dass es muss auf alle Fälle nochmal hier eine Ausgabe von Chaosradio geben, eine Telekom Hass-Sendung.
Ich glaube, das tut bitter Not.
Wir sollten doch echt kurz vor der Aktienausgabe machen. Genau.
Ja, wenn es dann passieren geht.
Ruf jetzt bitte nicht alle an und erzählt uns, was ihr Schlimmes mit der Telekom erlebt habt. Da kennen wir auch ganz viele Geschichten. Ich sage dir schon mal Tschüss.
Martin war es, ne? Stefan, danke dir.
Lass uns mal Kurzmeldung machen, Johnny.
Ja, wir machen gleich Kurzmeldung. Ich mache noch Musik, dann gibt es Kurzmeldung und dann geht es weiter. Gucken wir mal, ob der noch dran ist. Hallo, Chaosradio hier.
Nö, dann nicht.
Also so viel Zeit habe ich nicht.
Ulrich, mein Name. Wie geht's?
Ihr habt vorhin so über die Telekom gelästert. Ich kann überhaupt nicht klagen. Ich habe mir zu Hause hier einen Telefonanschluss bestellt, ganz normal. Nach drei Monaten kam jemand. Wunderbar.
Nach zwei Monaten schon?
Ja, ja, ja. Wollte installieren und drüben durch ist mir eingefallen, Mensch, ich brauch ja noch einen zweiten fürs Fax. Den haben sie dann auch gleich aufgeklemmt. Also innerhalb von vier Stunden habe ich den zweiten gekriegt. So, in dem zweiten Anschluss, da ist die Rechnungsadresse mein Chefgewinn. Weil hauptsächlich Fax und Firmen intern und hin und her. So, und für die Faxnummer praktisch gab es bis heute keine Rechnung. Seit drei Jahren habe ich schon ein paar Mal unsere Sekretärin nachgefragt, aber für diese Nummer gibt es überhaupt keine Rechnung.
Ich frage dich mal jetzt nicht nach deinem ganzen Namen und deinem Telefonnummer, würde ich sagen.
Nee, also klappt alles wunderbar. Es wurde zwar schon mal von der Telekom aus nachgefragt. Die haben mir auf das Fax eben eine Nachricht geschickt, bezüglich bla bla bla, irgendwas. Und ich soll mich mal unter der und der Telefonnummer bei der Telekom melden. Das habe ich dann auch mal gemacht. Und da habe ich auch jemanden herangekriegt, im Gegensatz zu euch, relativ schnell, ab drei Versuchen und habe dann nochmal die Büroadresse angegeben. Das war auch schon ein halbes Jahr her und es gab noch keine Rechnung dafür.
Na, hast du Glück.
Ja, überhaupt nicht, was ihr auf die Telekom schwimpft.
Naja, wir sind nicht in deiner Situation.
An deiner Stelle würde ich auch nicht schwimpfen.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Dann wünsche ich dir weiterhin noch viel Glück.
Es gibt eine Rubrik in dieser Sendung, die wir bisher noch nicht hatten, was daran liegt, dass wir so viele Anrufer heute hatten, aber wir werden das natürlich jetzt genau nachholen.
Es geht um Neues aus dem Internet.
Kurzmeldung Chaosradio. Wie das Wall Street Journal berichtet, haben zwei japanische Firmen, die Pachinko Spielhallen in Japan betreiben, erhebliche Verluste durch nachgebaute Geldspeicherkarten für ihre Automaten erlitten. Die vermutlich von organisierten Kriminellen in Umlauf gebrachten Karten kosteten die Spielhallenbetreiber angeblich 588 Millionen Dollar. Das Kartensystem war ursprünglich von der Polizei gefordert worden, um die grassierende Geldwäsche in der Glücksspielszene einzudämmen. Da die Spieler mit den Karten eine geringere Übersicht über ihre verzockten Gelder haben, waren die Umsätze nach der Einführung des Systems dramatisch gestiegen. Am 9. Mai wurden Millionen Bürger der amerikanischen Hauptstadt Opfer eines Softwarefehlers. Durch ein kleines Update, das endlich die grüne Welle realisieren sollte, wurde die Steuerung des Ampelsystems in den Wochenendemodus versetzt. Genau zur morgendlichen Raschauer. Zur Nachmittag war das Problem durch Einspielen der alten Software dann endlich gefixt. Vom bisher größten Computerfehler der amerikanischen Bankgeschichte waren letzte Woche einige hundert Kunden der First National Bank of Chicago betroffen. Durch eine kleine Softwareänderung hatten einige Kunden irrtumlicherweise dreistellige Millionenbeträge auf ihrem Konto. Diese Gesamtsumme überstieg die realen Einlagen der Bank um das Dreifache. Nochmal Bank Die Sicherheit von Bankdaten wurde beim Abbrand der Crédit Lyonnais mit Bank in Frankreich ernsthaft diskreditiert. Wie sich im Nachhinein herausstellte, lagen die Sicherheitskopien der Bankdaten vom Donnerstag regelmäßig bis Sonntag in den Rechnern. Als die Bank am Samstag abbrannte, war noch nicht einmal eine Sicherheitskopie der Daten vom Freitag vorhanden.
Das ist ja schon mal nicht schlecht. Na klar, finde ich auch.
Nee, also wirklich, ich muss echt mal sagen.
Es ist ja wirklich eine Kunst, bei euch rein zu kommen. Tja, bist du stolz?
Doch, jetzt ein bisschen schon, ja.
Wir feiern jeden Tag eine Party und wir hören euren Sender und das ist richtig genial, sag mal.
Das ist schön, jetzt weißt du auch, warum das so schwer ist durchzukommen.
Ja, ich glaube auch, wir feiern mehrere Party, wa?
Bei euch geht es ums Internet, Frank.
Na eigentlich reden wir über Telefone heute.
Telefone, ja. Ich bin gerade beim Kumpel, wir telefonieren jetzt zum Mondscheintarif.
Aber die Telekom sind nicht voll mitgewählt.
Wie macht ihr das jetzt um diese Zeit?
Mondscheintarif hängt da nicht an.
Das ist gerade ärgerlich, da kommt man endlich durch nach Stunden und dann rutscht mir das Ding aus, das ist blöd.
Hallo, Chaosradio hier.
Hallo, ich hab mal eine Frage, die das Telefon mit beeinflusst, sag ich mal. Es geht darum, ich hab einen T-Online-Anschluss. Und da gibt's ja diese E-Mail-Funktion, klappt alles wunderbar. Und da gibt's doch über Netscape diesen anderen E-Mail-Server, sag ich mal, was man auch wählen kann, über Netscape. Und da sagt der mir ständig, ja, können sie nicht nutzen, da sie keinen Namen eingegeben haben. Ich hab aber meinen Namen eingegeben.
Du musst ins Menü Options reingehen, Mail & News, Preferences. Und dort musst du deine E-Mail-Adresse und deinen vollen Namen eintragen. Klickst auf OK, dann funktioniert das. Sofern du einen richtigen Mailserver eingetragen hast.
Super Sache. Ich bin ja nicht ganz blüten, nur so ein bisschen. Habe ich alles getan. Habe ich alles getan.
Ich kann mich doch mal bei der T-Online...
Ja, Moment, Moment, hast du einen Mailserver eingetragen?
Ja, natürlich, ja, ich hab den Mailserver eingetragen. Wenn ich ganz normal über T-Online gehe, habe ich meinen Mailserver über T-Online. Und wenn ich aber sage, ich möchte meinen Netscape Server haben, dann sagt man mir, okay, machen wir alles, mach den auf und sagt, denn schninken geht nicht, da kein Name getragen. Der Name steht da was drin.
Ja, das würde ich jetzt auch gerne wissen.
Der Name steht drin.
Nee, was ist denn ein Netscape Mailserver? Also dieser Begriff von uns ist lang nicht geläufig.
Na gut, dann habe ich vielleicht das ausgedrückt. Du kannst doch ganz normal über T-Online machen, die ganze Sache. Und wenn du ein Netscape aufmachst, hast du denn da auch noch mal einen E-Mailservice, sag ich mal.
Das kann aber auch was nicht.
Die Telekom kriegt Geld dafür, dass sie dir diese Fragen beantwortet.
Die Idee war schon nicht... Also ich müsste mir praktisch selber mal erst mal über den Netscape E-Mailservice, den sie da anbieten, mir selber...
Ja, probier das mal. Ich wirke das jetzt auch total ungern ab, aber darum geht es eigentlich heute gar nicht.
Na gut, das war schon eine Hilfe. Danke euch, ne?
Ja, also das mit der Telekom das Problem können wir, danke dir. Das Problem kennen wir, aber da kann man nichts machen hier.
Das ist aber ein schöner Rat von euch, da ruft auch bei der Telekom an, wo ihr selber wisst, wie schwierig das ist.
Wo sind wir denn jetzt?
Wir müssen irgendwann mit Telefon Sex anfangen, ist nach 12, ist klar. Ich wollte sagen...
Ja, ich will mit Telefon Sex anfangen. Es gibt übrigens was richtig Schönes.
Wenn ihr öfter mal auf der Autobahn unterwegs seid, kann ich euch nur raten, investiert die 12 Mark oder 15 Mark, kauft euch eine Telefon Sex Kassette. Wenn ihr zu mehreren unterwegs seid, legt sie uns auf der Radio rein. Ich schwöre euch für 20 Minuten beste Unterhaltung von, und das ist jetzt nicht abwirkend gemeint, aber von sächsischen Damen mit Sprachfedern, die hocherotische Geschichten von einem Blatt Papier, das man rascheln hört, vorlesen.
Das ist großartig.
Besser kann man das machen.
Sani, mach mal nach.
Jetzt wäre ich ein bisschen rot. Das könnt ihr wohl nicht sehen.
Das ist ein Lachradio.
Es gibt diese eine wunderbare Stelle, die ich liebe.
Ja, jetzt sitzen jetzt ein bisschen die Hände und andere Kassetteile. Es gibt diese eine wunderbare Stelle, wo sie auf dieser Kassette sagt.
Diese Stelle ist unglaublich. Also wer irgendwie ein bisschen Humor hat für solche Sachen, dem empfehle ich diese Kassette.
Ich glaube, das war Teil 3 oder so. Ja, schön rausgebracht. Danke Jungs.
Der soll ja keine Platte auflegen, oder?
Nehmen wir die hier.
Gut, wir sind jetzt ein bisschen in Zeitverzögerung gekommen, weil...
Immer?
Wir drei Gewinner haben anstelle von einem.
Das macht uns aber gar nichts.
Da müssen wir eben ein bisschen mehr nach Preisen baggern bei verschiedenen Firmen.
Besonders in der nächsten Sendung, was diejenigen gewonnen haben.
Und werden nach dem Fritz-Info, dann noch Musik und dann kommt Fritz-Info.
Und dann noch was Telefons.
Jetzt könnt ihr mal hören...
Oder Telefons. Ja, ist dann...
Nein, Frank, dann kommt Telefons.
Telefon Terror erst und Fax.
So ein paar kleine Fax.
Ja, so ein paar Kleinigkeiten.
Und dann ist aber wirklich Telefons-Sex.
Nee, du bist schon auf Sendung.
Ich bin schon auf Sendung?
Hey, da wusste ich mal gleich, was so ist das.
Ich hatte eure Nummer schon vor dem ersten gewählt. Ich war auch schon durch und ich hatte den Moderator dran. Auch die Leitung ist zusammengebrochen und dann habe ich eure Nummer hier, eure Gewinnernummer, zehnmal angerufen und bin bei fünf verschiedenen Leuten gelandet, die alle mal um Krips kennen sie nicht.
Und sie hatten immer eine 3 statt 698.
Das letzte Stell ist jetzt grausam.
Nee, dann hast du aber wirklich eine falsche Nummer gehabt.
Nein, soll ich so sagen?
Der Moderator von euch, der dran war, hat mich auch bestätigt. Die war richtig, aber die Telekom hat irgendwas verpeilt. Da war jemand dran. Diese Nummer, die hier alle Leute anrufen, die ist sehr versteckt irgendwo in den Tiefen von Berlin und die meisten Leute, die abnehmen, wenn diese Nummer nur etwas falsch gewählt wird, haben keine Ahnung worum es geht.
Also du hast wirklich nicht mit mir geredet, ich schwöre.
Ich hatte die Nummer aber dem Typen gesagt und der meinte, er verbindet mich mal durch und dann macht es knirsch, knackt wie eine schlechte Funkverbindung und dann war weg.
Ja, dann hab ich von einer reingelegt.
Du hast aber wirklich nicht mit mir geredet, wirklich nicht.
Was würdest du machen, wenn dich einer anruft und sagt, hey du, jetzt bin ich endlich beim Radio durch. Du würdest ihn halt durchstellen.
Wir hatten genau bis jetzt vier Anrufe. Der erste war von jemandem, der wusste worum es geht. Der hatte eher zum Schatz anruft, den haben wir auch nicht gewinnen lassen. Und die anderen drei haben es wirklich rausgefunden.
Du hast wirklich nicht mit mir geredet.
Also ich musste selber rausgefunden haben, weil ich einen FMF-Decoder am Radio angeschlossen habe und die Nummer 100% richtig habe.
Ja, pass auf, dann erkläre ich dir woran das liegt.
Vielleicht, nur vielleicht, pass auf, vielleicht war die Nummer dann gerade von jemandem anders besetzt und du hast jemanden anders herangekriegt, der dann an den jeweiligen Apparat gegangen ist, über den wir eigentlich eine Rufanleitung gemacht haben.
Da war das also so, dass wenn die Nummer einmal besetzt war, ist man dauernd falsch gelandet.
Sozusagen.
Genau. Da war ich ja durch und durch richtig dummes Telekom, weil die Leitung zusammengebrochen ist, hat das jetzt nicht geklappt. Das kann einem richtig ärgern jetzt.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen ärgerlich, aber du kannst dich beruhigen. Du warst dann tatsächlich zu langsam. Die Leitung war dann schon besetzt. Du warst dann also nicht der Erste.
Ich war ja schon einmal durch. Einmal hatte ich doch schon jemanden dran.
Aber nicht uns.
Jetzt hast du einfach verloren, jetzt musst du damit gehen. Ja, mache ich auch. Kann ich noch ein paar Leute grüßen, die alle mit mir mitprobiert haben? Ja, die ganze Runde von Kanal 28 hier, insbesondere Neophyte, Stupi, Talion, Ossi, alle Datenselect-Benutzer und alle User von der Mysterious Worlds BWS. Genau, die haben mir alle geholfen. Und wir haben hier zu zehnt nicht ganz. Das haben wir gewählt und immer nur Freizeichen, Freizeichen, Freizeichen. Nächstes Mal machen wir es noch komplizierter, für der Beweisung, dass ihr die Profis seid.
Nächstes Mal wird es schwieriger, aber auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für das Mitprobieren und ärgert euch nicht so.
Das Sportsgeist zählt, ihr wart dabei.
Selber, bis dann, ciao.
Ja, siehst du mal, da sind einige Leute sich rausgefordert gefühlt, ne?
Das kriegen wir raus. Was ansatzweise zu tun mit Telefon, weil sie schöne Zahle drin vorkommen. Also wenn überhaupt dann die beste deutschsprachige Band ist zur Zeit.
Aber hallo. Also ich muss jetzt aber nochmal die Loser des Monats loswerden. Das haben sich ja alle mitverfolgt. Die Loser des Monats sind absolut und mit Abstand die Rehensmartenführer. Erstens entführt man keine Leute. Zweitens schon gar nicht den netten Rehensmart. Und drittens mietet man dann nicht hinterher auf seinen eigenen Namen in Spanien den Mietwagen.
Das machen wir einfach nicht.
Nicht beim deutschen Unternehmen.
Ich hab das auch nicht verstanden.
Na gut, da ist jetzt eine ganz andere Diskussion, die vielleicht dann doch politisch werden würde und mit Zigarettenmarken zu tun hat. Das soll uns jetzt erstmal egal sein. Zum Thema Fax möchte ich kurz noch was hören von euch.
Ja, Faxeln.
Es gibt zum Beispiel Faxwerbung, das nervt total.
Und ich hab dann den von euch benannten Trick, den ihr vielleicht auch schonmal angewandt. Ich hab ne Weile Faxwerbung bekommen und hab dann auch zurückgefaxt. Man möge das auch bitte einstellen, das hat nichts benützt. Also alle drei, vier Tage kamen von irgendeiner Firma und welche Computerangebote, weiß ich, woher die die Faxnummer hatten. Ist ja nicht so schwer. Und irgendwann hat das so sehr genervt, dass ich dann das gemacht hab, was wahrscheinlich von euch auch ein Tipp ist.
Ja, na, es gibt da viele Möglichkeiten. Ich fang mal mit den Netten an. Einer zum Beispiel ist, man hat ein Faxmodem und schreibt sich ein kleines Programm, das immer einen Zeilen vorschub und dann ein Seitenende provoziert. Mit ein bisschen Glück hat das gegenüber einem Faxgerät mit automatischem Papier-Abschneidemechanismus, der dann ungefähr einen Zentimeter breite Papierschnipsel produziert. Das macht man ein paar Stunden lang, wenn es ein Ortsgespräch ist, und am nächsten Morgen hat er 80 Meter Confetti in seinem Büro. Das ist eine ganz feine Sache. Das andere Versicherungen übernehmen in vielen Fällen schon nicht mehr die Schäden, die entstehen, wenn irgendwelche Leute ihre Faxgeräte über Nacht am Netz lassen, weil es vorkommen kann, dass sie, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, Defekte oder was man sich da vorstellen kann, schwarze Faxe, also komplette schwarze Seiten, zugeschickt bekommen. Bei solchen Faxgeräten, die zum Beispiel einen Thermodruckkopf im Gerät haben, wird dieser Thermodruckkopf mitunter so heiß, dass das Gerät anfängt zu brennen. Deswegen sollte man das unter gar keinen Umständen machen, irgendjemandem schwarze Faxe zu schicken.
Sollte man auf keinen Fall machen, besonders wenn man...
Ja, vor allem nicht nachts, auch gar nicht damals, als die Telefonkosten geringer waren und schon gar nicht, wenn man irgendwie Faxwerbung kriegt oder so.
Nee, wenn das erstmal richtig durch ist, ist das bestimmt Brandstiftung oder so irgendwas. Also das kann auch richtig böse werden.
So sollte man darauf achten, dass es nicht um einen Laserdruckerfax hatte, da ist dann nämlich nur der Ton heralle.
Ja, andere Fax-Tipps? Was ist denn zum Beispiel, gibt es irgendwelche Tipps von euch, das jetzt völlig unvorbereitet? Nehmen wir an, man hat kein ISDN und kann zum Beispiel Rufnummern nicht erkennen, das funktioniert auch nur in wenigen Fällen, wenn man zum Beispiel anonyme Anrufe bekommt. Also bevor man da bei der Telekom irgendwie beantragt, Fangschaltung und so ein Kram, gibt es da irgendwelche Tipps?
Ja, aber die können wir jetzt hier.
Wie man die anonymen Anrufer los wird? Ja, also die beste Methode anonyme Anrufer los zu werden, also insbesondere die, die jetzt einen konkret belästigen, ist anzufangen, sie zu belästigen. Also ihnen genauso zu kommen, wie sie versuchen anzukommen.
Man muss ja bei dem Nummer wissen.
Achso, und in dem Moment, wo sie anrufen, sie verlieren dann ziemlich schnell den Spass.
Wie machst du das?
Bei der ganzen Obszön-Anrufer, von denen du mir mal erzählst, du kommst?
Ja, ich werd halt einfach immer noch eine Ebene obszöner als ihn.
Also früher ging es bei einer Logenvermittlungsstelle, wo es noch keine Begrenzung für die Lautstärke gab, einfach nur trillerfrei zu nehmen. Schmerzenssinnig, bei digitalen Limitertrennen geht das nicht mehr so gut, aber den richtig zu belästigen und ihm sehr intime Fragen zu stellen, hilft oft.
Das ist schön, dass du wieder anrufst. Da kann ich die ganzen Abend schon auf deinen Anruf gewartet.
Da können sich dann auch interessante Gespräche draus ergeben und die Telefonkostümungen auf der anderen Seite zu geben.
Einfach nicht ärgern lassen.
So, wir kommen jetzt zum Thema Telefonsex.
Nee, doch noch nicht. Telefonsex, hallo? Hallo?
Hallo, Telefonsex, hallo?
Jetzt hast du dich keiner angesprochen, schade ich das.
Telefonica erotica online.
Es gibt bestimmt einige Leute, die sich fragen, was man eigentlich hört, wenn man bei diesen teuren Nummern anruft. Zum Beispiel diese Konferenz-Schaltungen. Ich gebe das offen zu, ich habe das mal probiert, das ist Jahre her. Es war zu Testzwecken, also für die Sendung. Halt das mal gemacht, da hört man dann ungefähr in diesen Konferenz-Schaltungen, also wo es so heißt, Parfee-Hotline und so, hört man ungefähr 16 männliche Anrufer, die alle sagen, hallo?
Stehen da irgendwelche Frauen draußen?
Hallo? Hallo?
Hallo, sind da auch Frauen da?
Hallo?
Ah, hallo, hier ist der Jürgen aus Bremen, sind da Frauen?
Da sind übrigens auch Frauen, und zwar bezahlte Frauen, fast alle, die da sind, sind eben bezahlte Frauen, weil Frauen solche Dienste eigentlich überhaupt nicht anrufen und die tun dann halt so, als wären sie rein zufällig da.
Falls übrigens eine Frau zuhört, die sowas tatsächlich doch schon mal probiert hat und vielleicht auch irgendwie nette Erfahrungen hat, könnt ihr natürlich anrufen. 0331 für Podstamp, 74 81 110, wenn Tim jetzt behauptet, da rufen Frauen sowieso nicht an. BTX zum Beispiel, diese Live-Chat-Geschichten muss man auch mal dazu sagen, das sind bezahlte Studenten, Männer wissen, was Männer wollen.
Oder Roboter.
Oder Robs, wobei die natürlich dann nicht ganz so spannend sind, aber da Studenten am besten wissen, was andere Studenten wollen.
Zu dem Thema nochmal, dass keine Frauen anrufen, es gibt da irgendwie jetzt auch so neue Varianten, dass so eine Chat-Line irgendwie zwei Rufnummern hat, einmal eine 190er, wo dann nur die Männer anrufen sollen, also die bezahlen dann halt dafür, und dann halt eine 130er für Frauen, das heißt, die können dann kostenlos anrufen da. Das funktioniert wohl angeblich auch.
Man kriegt aber kein Geld dafür.
Man kriegt kein Geld dafür.
Was hindert jetzt die Männer dran, die 0130 zu hüllen?
Ja, da sitzt halt irgendwer, der das überprüft.
Das können die ja gar nicht feststellen.
Ist hier etwas?
Nein, nein. Hallo, hier ist René.
René?
René? René?
Telefonsext.
René, was hast du gerade an?
Ich habe ja das Radio heute manchmal leiser.
Warte mal, René.
René?
René, was hast du denn gerade an?
Ich halte jetzt immer kurz mein Radio an.
Nein, was hast du da drunter an?
Trickst du Leder oder Lack?
Ich bin jetzt immer noch mal zum Fax zurück.
Oh, deine Nummer...
René? René, du machst mich ganz wild.
Ruf mich morgen wieder an, René.
Entschuldigung, René, aber jetzt das Telefon. Chaosradio hier, hallo.
Schreckt.
Jetzt haben wir auch ein gutes Thema. Aber es geht hier um Spaß mit dem Telefon. Das ist interessant, irgendwie komisch. Ich frage mich, wie das so zu einem Business wird.
Wir haben ja irgendwie was. So ein Sample ist irgendjemand untergelaufen, der hat sich verwehlt.
Gehen Sie auf dicke Titten. Ich habe die größten Brüste und den riesigsten Hintern der Hieb. Meine Tochter oder ich wüchsen für 40, Schnellverkehr 50, französisch Verkehr 60, Titten für 70, französisch gegenseitig 80, Vibratorspiele 90, ab 100 Mark Luft sprudel unter Wasser, ganz Chaos Radio.
Chaos Radio nähert sich dem Ende.
13 Minuten noch zu hören hier. Wir haben uns unterhalten über witzige Dinge, die man mit dem Telefon machen kann.
Damit, dass die Leute das besser merken können.
Ich hab mir keine Einzige gemerkt.
Das ist ja auch nicht die Zielgruppe.
Natürlich bin ich die Zielgruppe.
Ich bin 24.
Bist du einsam? Nein, aber jung, männlich, hat seine Telefonrichtung nicht unter Kontrolle.
Jung, männlich, hat seine Telefonrichtung nicht unter Kontrolle.
Schön ausgedrückt.
Ja, ich mein prinzipiell, ich bin männlich. Insofern bin ich Zielgruppe.
Naja.
Und ich hab mal eines Telefon. Hallo?
Hallo?
Das muss ein Scheißjob sein, Telefon.
Ich saß euch hier.
Das ist ein Scheißjob.
Ich kenn das aus eigener Erfahrung.
Kennt ihr jemand, Studenten oder Studentinnen, die sowas mal gemacht haben?
Hab ich dir doch vorhin erzählt.
Ich hab das mal ein anderthalb Jahr lang in einer Firma gearbeitet, wo ich zwar nicht ausführende Kräfte...
Daher kenn ich deine Stimme. Vielleicht sogar mehr als das.
Was ich anhabe? Eine schwarze Hose und ein Rolli.
Ne, jetzt die Hose. Felix, ich mag schwarze Rollis.
Echt? Ne, ich hab ne schwarze Hose und nen grauen Rolli.
Siehst du dich aus, John?
Ich bitte, ich kann noch mal Hose, wenn ihr das sagt. Ich übersah nicht, und ich sitz vor ihm.
Es ist absolut heftig, dass ich mal bei euch durchgekommen bin, das ist das erste Mal, ich ruf nämlich aus Magdeburg an.
Aha, ist das schwieriger aus Magdeburg anzurufen?
Ich weiß es nicht, also ich sitz hier gerade auf meiner Dienststelle, wo du wirst, auf der Bahnhofsmission. Im Prinzip heftig Langeweile.
Wie, wo arbeitest du auf der Bahnhofsmission? Da ist Langeweile angesagt, da kommen keine Leute vorbei und brauchen Trinkwasser zu essen.
Ja, morgens kommen die Obdachlosen in den Abend und holen sich hier Fräschen und so. Aber ich mein, vorhin hatten wir noch einen Rollstuhlfahrer, den mussten wir aus dem Zug holen und ein Kumpel hat den abgeholt. Der hat auch Zivildienstleid von Maltesern, jetzt fährt die dann immer nach Hause wieder und so.
Und wenn du nicht beim Radio anrufst, kann es dann sein, dass du vielleicht einen dieser, wie soll ich sagen, dieser Telefondienste nutzt, die im Fernsehen gerade nachts öfter für einsame Menschen beworben werden.
Gut, aber hast du das schon?
Moment, ich bin nicht einsam, ich quatsche ja mit dir.
Ja, aber wenn du es nicht mit dem Radio probierst, sind hier Besetztes.
Also mit anderen Worten...
Ich hab hier gerade einen Brief von meiner Freundin.
Na ja, in der einen, ja. Lies mal vor.
Ja, nee, ich lese den ganzen Brief vor, okay?
Wie kurz ist er denn?
Mein Lieber Felix, ich weiß, dass ich dich vorhin sehr verletzt habe. Mir selber hat das hinterher wehgetan, dass ich so gemein zu dir war. Du hast mich vorhin ziemlich ehrlich gemacht mit dem, was du gesagt hast. Ich konnte mir das wirklich nicht mehr länger anhören. Ich wollte einfach nur noch weg. Felix, ich halte wirklich nicht wieder voll genug. Mir hat alles klar geworden, wenn du geraucht hast. Für mich ist das der totale Schwachsinn.
Felix? Ganz kurz, was hast du gesagt?
Was ich gesagt habe? Irgendetwas zu mir gesagt, weißt du? Und das kam mir vor, als ob das irgendwie Lammfraud war, wie im Buch, weißt du?
Felix, ich würde mal jetzt einfach so, ich meine, ich verstehe auch nicht so viel von Frauen, aber ich würde schon mal ganz vorsichtig sagen, dass du ziemlich verkackt hast. Ja, ich denke schon, vor allem, wenn du den Brief live im Radio vorliegst.
Das ist sehr positiv. Ich kann ja auch mal was Positives sagen. Manchmal bin ich eben doch froh, dass du anders bist als manch anderer.
Ich?
Ach so, ich dachte, er meint nicht.
Ich mag nicht alle außergewöhnlichen Dinge, was? Ich mag nicht alle außergewöhnlichen Dinge an dir, wie du weißt. Ich mag eben, wie du mir deinen Vertrauen schenkst und ich dir meines geben kann.
Na ja, ist das schon mal was, Felix.
Ich meine, da kann man auch stolz drauf sein.
Aber weißt du, wir haben uns jetzt so viel gestritten und ich war letztes Wochenende auch in Berlin mit dir und so. Aber weißt du, nach dem Streit ist dann wieder Ruhe, weißt du.
Ja, das ist ja noch eine andere Sendung.
Gut, diese Stelle muss ich nochmal zusammenfassen. Also Telefonsexte schlägt nicht ein. Irgendwie schlägt das nicht ein.
Na, ihr habt ja kein Glück mit mir. Wir hatten ja eigentlich gehofft, wir sitzen 2, 4, 5. Ihr seid 5, ich bin einer.
Also hier sitzen 6 gesunde junge Männer und haben gehofft, oh, jetzt kriegen wir den Telefon.
Hallo?
Ich hab die ganze Zeit auf dich gemacht, Peter.
Ach nee, jetzt ist Feierabend.
Chaos Radio, auf Fress, wir haben geredet, überall witzige Dinge, die man uns im Telefon anstellen kann. Ich check noch einmal zum Schluss die E-Mail, wollt ihr noch Abschlusswörter sagen?
Ja, du könnt den Macintosh noch mal einschalten zum Schluss, dann haben wir zumindest noch eine Tastenhintergrundbemalung. Falsche Maustaste?
Drücken Sie diese Taste bitte nicht noch einmal.
Tja, ansonsten haben wir uns eigentlich schon auf ein Thema zu fliehen.
Ich glaube nicht.
Der Mac läuft, das ist ein...
Also die nächste Sendung, das überlegen wir uns dann, was wir da machen, da fällt uns ganz bestimmt was ein.
Wir müssen auf alle Fälle noch mal die Telekom Sendung machen, wir müssen auf alle Fälle noch mal die Chaos-Legenden Sendung machen.
Und Schlüsselungen wollten wir gleich auch mal machen.
Das hat man schon angebaut. Das sind immer so technisch trockene Themen.
Wie werden die dann auf dem Internet?
Ich hab eine Idee. Multimedia!
Nein, wie schließe ich meinen CD-Rom laufend an einem PC an?
Das weiß doch keiner, wie soll man das in drei Stunden gehen?
Das mit den Computern, ne? Also ich kenn nur Leute, die den ganzen Tag...
Das war Chaosradio auf Fritz, ich geh weiter mit Martin Peters auf den Night Flight.
Ich bedanke mich beim Chaosradio.
Also gut, dass ihr hier wart und sage Tschüss.
Ja, wir sagen alle auch mal Tschüss und so, ne?
Tschüss.